[Musique]
christophe salah bourdillon bonsoir nous
recevons pour une chaîne interne et qui
s'appelle signe que review nous sommes
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
bonjour merci sky pour votre invitation
donc je suis christophe stella
bourdillon je suis professeur en
intelligence économique en est qui en
éthique en économie j'enseigne surtout
sur le campus artem qui regroupe l'école
icn business school l'école des mines de
nancy et l'enesad qui est l'école des
beaux-arts et design de nancy
j'enseigne également dans plusieurs
écoles d'ingénieurs j'ai la chance
d'être professeur invité à polytechnique
j'enseigne aussi à centrale supélec et
j'enseigne dans sept pays sur une
quinzaine de campus en français
également en anglais
avant d'être professeur c'est un choix
que j'ai fait à 47 ans de devenir
professeur avant d'être professeur j'ai
travaillé pendant 25 ans d'entreprise
toujours à des postes de direction est
toujours à l'international aux achats à
l'export en fusions acquisitions donc à
47 ans j'ai décidé de devenir professeur
parce que je trouvais que les jeunes que
j'avais en stage et les jeunes en
général que l'ont accueilli en
entreprise étaient souvent pas très
aguerris au niveau international au
niveau négociations etc et j'avais envie
de transmettre mon expérience
donc j'ai pris le risque de devenir
professeur et de perdre 70 % de salaire
parce qu'il faut le savoir les
professeurs ne sont pas très bien payé
quand vous avez du privé et donc je
voyage beaucoup j'ai la chance d'être
allé dans plus de 100 pays et là je
rentre de chine où j'ai enseigné à
chengdu et à shanghai sur trois campus
voilà et vous parlait cinq langues voilà
j'ai la chance de parler plusieurs
langues je ne parle pas chinois met
d'ailleurs à ce propos a enfin antezana
déjà aujourd'hui on va parler indigence
économie courir les chine oui on va par
les médias ont parlé propagande
construction de l'information
construction de vidéos bombe que vous
avez vous les nommez on commence par la
chine parce que vous revenez fraîchement
de chine
comment comment le peuple chinois
comment les étudiants chinois perçoivent
la france
la première fois que je suis allé en
chine c'était il ya 30 à environ et je
me souviens avoir être allé sur le bund
la grande allée près du word peau à
shanghai et là j'ai été accompagné par
une personne de l'ambassade et 2
chinoise est en phase ii du bund il y
avait un énorme terrain vague qui
s'appelle pudding et je me souviens de
la jeune chinoise qui étaient là qui
représentait la municipalité de shanghai
elle me dit dans 30 ans il y aura
plusieurs new york devant et à l'époque
je prends ça voilà comme une vérité et
je me souvient peut-être trop parce que
la personne de l'ambassade me prend par
la manche et me dit je me souviendrai
toujours ces chinois c'est chinoise
quelle arrogance et ça c'était juste
après la mort de mao donc mao est mort
en 76 tenzing venait d'arriver et y
lancer l'ouverture de la chine et à
cette époque là il faut être honnête peu
de gens croyaient que la chine un jour
deviendrait numéro un mondial alors ce
qui est intéressant j'ai eu plus de gens
cv les experts patentés de la place
publique enfin c'est un peu la même
chose comme l'ex union soviétique et son
effondrement c'est ça je serais tenté de
dire que en europe on est peut-être très
européenne très européen centré et on a
du mal à voir les pays émergents
rappelez-vous pour la première guerre
mondiale quand les américains ont émergé
on l'a raté bon après on a raté
la corée du sud en a raté le japon et ce
en attendant c'est un petit peu à
mépriser les pays qui sont pas européens
et à penser que nous ne pourrons jamais
émergé finalement moi même j'avais
appris quand j'étais étudiant que la
chine ferait partie des pays pauvres
pour l'éternité finalement et personne
ne pensait que la chine pourrait
franchement devenir numéro un lorsqu est
intéressant justement là-dessus j'ai eu
la chance d'assister à puce à plusieurs
reprises à shanghai à des cours sur la
france par des professeurs chinois donc
nous on sait bien ce que l'on dit sur la
chine en france ce qui est intéressant
c'est d'écouter ce que les chinois
disent la france est alors beaucoup de
choses sont intéressantes et il commence
en disant la france est l'archétype de
l'immobilisme je me souviens le premier
cours que auquel j'ai assisté en 60 en
2016 donc c'était 40 ans voilà après la
mort de mao la france était présenté
comme un pays immobile et je me souviens
du prof devant un amphi de 200 personnes
il faisait comme ça
et donc ça s'était intéressée doute oui
c'est un effet de loupe mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir pourquoi
comment les analyses la chose alors eux
analysent déjà le fait que l'europe
a tendance à pousser à l'immobilisme et
surtout aussi que la démocratie c'est
intéressant que la démocratie est
devenue en europe une démocratie dévoyée
ils vous disent la démocratie en europe
c'est devenu un peu un jeu de quilles
dans lequel lé meilleur candidat
n'émerge pas et dans lequel finalement
il est plus important de faire tomber
les autres candidats que de
est-ce que je peux regarder l'équipe
technique pour savoir si et du son
[Musique]
il ya du son et ses revenus donc le son
est revenu ici de ne pas nous faire des
blagues comme ça sur nés sur les enfants
merci serait bien
christophe encore
voilà donc je disais qu effectivement
dans l'esprit des chinois ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir pourquoi et
comment les analyses alors je reviens un
peu en vrac les frais ils disent les
français aiment beaucoup discuté mais
n'aime pas décidé et ce en est si vrai
que dans les cours sur la france vous
avez un quiz que j'ai vu où on vous
explique les français si vous voulez on
vous propose quatre options petite
option à les français aiment discuter et
m décidé les français aiment discuter
même pas décidé
c'est bon temps frais voilà ok donc je
continue et donc effectivement les
les chinois pour eux l'une des raisons
qui fait que la france est immobile
c'est que effectivement les français ont
du mal à décider et là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que eux disent en
revanche que la force du parti
communiste ils reconnaissent que la
démocratie chinoise est une démocratie
imparfaite mais ils disent la grande
force du parti communiste c'est qu'en
fait ils décident la grande force du
parti unique c'est qu'ils dessinent que
le parti communiste c'est quoi ces 98
millions de personnes qui effectivement
la phrase structure enfin la
colonne vertébrale de la chine et qui
impulse le développement en chine voilà
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre
au niveau du développement chinois c'est
que les chinois ne
fonctionne un peu différemment des
français quand on parle par exemple des
droits de l'homme
les chinois vous disent toujours oui
mais vous me parlez des droits de
l'homme isolé nous en chine
on considère qu'un individu ait fait
partie d'un groupe donc nous ce que l'on
défend dans notre culture c'est la force
du groupe c'est pas la force de
l'individu c'est la force du groupe et
ce qui est important pour un chinois
c'est que le groupe soit fort d'abord et
avant tout et alors ils nous disent oui
vous en europe vous émanciper de votre
état de votre famille et c'est parce que
les groupes ne marche pas nous en chine
on pense que les groupes marche et
chacun va jouer pour que le groupe
marche bien et c'est pour ça si vous
voulez que
certains
je dirais certains certaines
caractéristiques de la société
occidentale
ne nous impacte pas parce que finalement
on va jouer le groupe d'abord et avant
tout alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on joue le
groupe intéressant de comprendre
pourquoi les chinois jouent le groupe
puisque l'individu c'est parce que ils
vous disent ce que j'abandonne au niveau
individuel au niveau du groupe en fait
si le groupe marche bien le groupe va me
rendre au centre donc c'est pas c'est
pas qu'ils jouent le groupe pour le
groupe c'est que ils savent très bien
que tous ensemble ils seront plus forts
l'union fait la force un exemple dès que
j'arrive à shanghai ocs à chengdu en
avion chaque fois notre correspondante
chinoise me dis donc j'arrive avec tous
mes étudiants est ce que vous arrivez à
la française ou es ce que vous avez à la
chinoise arrivée à la france est si on
arrive tous ensemble on prend notre
bagage on traverse la douane en chacun
enfin à la française individuellement et
chacun met son bagage dans le bus et
puis s'assied dans le bus tout seul
arrivé à la chinoise c'est attendent
tous ensemble soul et le les bagages
ensuite on passe la douane tous ensemble
on voit aux toilettes tous ensemble on
va au but au but sans qu'on rentre dans
le bus tous ensemble c'est vraiment dans
leur culture les chinois sont vraiment
fonctionne beaucoup en groupe c'est la
force du groupe alors par exemple je
dirais une autre un autre point qui est
important c'est que ils vous disent vous
en démocratie souvent le problème de la
démocratie c'est que quand ça va pas
finalement vous avez tendance un peu a
coulé tous ensemble nous quand on joue
le groupe on peut on peut prendre le
risque de sacrifier une partie du groupe
ce qui fera hurler tous leurs pertes on
peut prendre le risque de sacrifier une
partie du groupe pour que le groupe
rebondissent et que le groupe se
développe et donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment ancré dans la culture
chinoise et que nous européens on a du
mal on a du mal à comprendre donc il ya
cette notion 8 démocratie qui part très
là bas qui parle pas beaucoup aux points
wii il considère que le concept de
démocratie est un concept pour les
déstabiliser parce que quelque part
c'est donner plus de poids aux individus
donc quelque part c'est reda division
alors que eux ils sont fondamentalement
c'est dans le groupe ça c'est vraiment
c'est important alors ce qui est
important aussi c'est de comprendre que
dans ce cadre là la notion d'inégalité
par rapport à d'autres personnes n'a pas
le même poids parce que finalement ce
que l'on voit c'est le groupe et la
fierté de beaucoup de chinois et ça
c'est aussi l'ordre social confucéen
sais si je suis numéro 27 c'est pas de
devenir numéro 25 c'est pas devient
numéro 23 s'est pas devenir numéro un
c'est de très très bien joué mon rôle
dans le groupe dette si je suis numéro
27 il faut que je sois numéro un set
parfait ce qu'ils espèrent c'est le jour
de l'enterrement c'est pas qu'on dise
c'est dommage il était numéro 27 il
aurait pu être numéro 20 non c'est qu'on
dise il a été un super numéro 27 ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très très
loin de notre culture adou voyez sur les
inégalités aussi dans le même
dans le prolongement de ce que je dis
souvent on me dit mais c'est incroyable
parce que les chinois il ya des
inégalités c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
d'égalité quand même 1 entre le paysan
des rizières et plus certains
milliardaires comme jack ma ou d'autres
bons mais ils vont vous dire nous ce que
l'on voit c'est pas les inégalités ce
que l'on voit c'est sur cinq générations
l'enrichissement la population ce que
l'on va comparer c'est notre arrière
grand mère notre grand mère notre mère
nous mêmes notre fille on voit la
progression et on va pas changer si vous
voulez un système qui nous enrichit
d'autant qu'il distille les chinois la
chine est organisée aujourd'hui comme
une entreprise c'est à dire que c'est
pas une nation en face situation mais
c'est pas un pays comme new york il
faisait comme une entreprise ou cominar
mais alors les deux oui c'est une bonne
effectivement comme une entreprise aussi
comme une armée
mais autour des patriarches c'est
quelque chose aussi qui est très hachée
doit c'est-à-dire que ils vous diront
pourquoi voulez vous changer de chef si
le chef est bon lord le chef est bon
l'ordre social est bon le parti
communiste enrichi on continue alors on
a beau essayer de leur dire il ya
peut-être d'autres options constat pour
l'instant il considère moi je suis assez
frappé par hong kong qu'est ce qu'ils
considèrent comme bon il considère comme
bon de manger un peu plus de porc par
rapport à la famille qu'ils ont pu
exploiter pendant des années et qu'ils
considèrent comme bon le fait que sur la
scène internationale la chine se fassent
respecter comme l' empire du milieu ils
considèrent comme bon de prendre les
îles de construire des îles en mer de
chine de revendiquer sa italia des skis
alors c'est dire comme bon l'écologie
par exemple oui oui oui alors la chine a
atteint sur moi je ne suis pas un expert
là je vais pas parler en tant qu'expert
de la chine je suis plutôt à marco polo
de la chine marco polo moderne quand
vous allez à shanghai vous verrez si
vous allez au sud vers le port de jan
chan vous verrez il ya énormément
d'éoliennes partout partout partout
partout il ya énormément de scooters
électriques partout partout partout au
point même où c'est dangereux parce
qu'on les entend pas souvent ils roulent
feux éteints que ça donc l'écologie oui
c'est quelque chose qui qui qu'ils ont
en tête alors se veut pas dire qu'à
pékin par exemple en hiver il n'y a pas
l'anticyclone de la pollution que c'est
un oui il ya ya dans certaines villes
charbonnières je pense à la ville de
taiyuan pas taïwanais taiwan qui est une
grosse ville charles ix où je suis allé
là aussi on avait du mal à respirer etc
mais bon à chengdu à chongqing et
serrage et pas trop senti problèmes de
pollution donc oui oui ils sont
conscients de ça ils sont conscients
le mode de domination ce qui est
intéressant c'est quelque part
implicitement dans votre question il ya
l'idée de la domination comment les
chinois finalement domine alors ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que la
technique naturel en asie et
papillonnant chine c'est pas la force
pas la force c'est la séduction messin
tour de nom pour le contournement mais
c'est la séduction sans affection la
force et après bon et c'est pour ça que
comme ils sont dans une logique de
séduction sans affection est dans une
logique de ne pas perdre la face il faut
bien comprendre quelque chose il ya
quelque chose de très très chinois c'est
ce qu'ils appellent le win win un le
gagnant gagnant mais attention quand on
discute avec des chinois les chinois
vous diront toujours le gagnant gagnant
chez loi il ya toujours un gagnant tu
vas perdre et le gagnant c'est nous mais
ils feront tous les chinois feront
toujours tout pour vous gagnez un peu un
peu mais attention nous en tant
qu'occidental il faut pas il faut pas
interpréter le fait que l'on gagne un
peu comme étant si vous voulez une une
victoire il faut toujours c'est les
chinois systématiquement le fond alors
que par exemple examen 15 je coupe c'est
moi mais les incas peuvent être dans le
windows c'est peut-être dans le gagnant
perdant je gagne tu peux regarder trump
seul gène pas bon avec les chinois c'est
différent ils vont toujours essayé
d'échafauder une politique où vous allez
gagner un peu la route de la soie est un
bon exemple donc ils investissent 1000
milliards dans les ports dans les voies
ferrées dans les aéroports donc voila
vous on va gagner un peu de vin mais
juste gagner beaucoup on va juste
prendre les miettes
ce qui vint alors nous ont
malheureusement rien ou français
pratiquement rien ce qui va rassasie ce
qui va rassasié doute fin passagère et
eux se considérait comme grand magnanime
césar oui exactement mais c'est l'heure
mais par exemple sur quand on regarde
ils ont investi
au pire et ils y construisent 1500 km
entre le pire et budapest ont investi à
bilbao valence et c'est là nous
malheureusement ils ont pratiquement
rien investi en france en revanche on
aura quand même les produits parce que
comme celui-ci européenne on aura les
produits mais on n'aura pas le petit
winch et loi bon tout net la petite
miette voilà non malheureusement là on
en est réduit à prendre que les mieux
maintenant
je pense que les chinois ils sont alors
les chevaux première question m'a dit
est ce que les choix sont conquérants
oui oui et oui maintenant oui d'accord
ce qui sont belliqueux jeu alors
l'appétit vient en mangeant l'appétit
l'attendant gens il faut savoir qu'il ya
six ans il ya six ans il n'avait pas un
seul porte-avions pas un seul portail
ont maintenant ils en ont deux un porte
avion d'occasion qu'ils ont achetés aux
ukrainiens qui s'appelle le liaoning un
autre qui est en essai qui doit tourner
l'année prochaine et puis un troisième
qui est en construction nucléaire on
verra ça marche ou pas un certain disent
bon c'est pas sûr je pourrais en faut
être prudent avec les chinois ils
arrivent souvent à leurs fins ils sont
bien allés sur la lune donc certes donc
il est chinois annonce e3 porte avions
doit nucléaire pour 2025 et en 2030 il
va le lancer trois nouveaux porte avions
nucléaire donc pour 2030 ils auront six
portes l'avion ce sera la deuxième
flotte de porte avions du monde après
les américains qu'ils en ont 11 et ce
sont des porte avions qui tourne entre
50 et
et 70 villes 80 80 mille tonnes les les
les américains ont des porte-avions à
100 mille tonnes environ voilà donc
l'appétit vient en mangeant les chinois
se développe au niveau porte-avions
quand on lance des porte-avions c'est
pas pour faire des ronds dans l'eau au
niveau du fleuve jaune violet dont on va
parler on va parler cheveux jaunes pour
parler pendant des heures et des heures
de l'heure bleue du tibet les barrages
hydrauliques est-ce que vous avez
discuté un petit peu de ce qui se passe
avec les ouigours et chine alors moi je
suis allé il ya longtemps
alors que le cimt yang fait partie des
quatre des cinq régions autonomes
chinoises donc ce sont des ce sont des
régions un peu particulière
et là vous avez quand même pas mal de
hann donc les ouigours c'est entre 7 et
10 millions de personnes des musulmans
c'est le bout de l'arc turcophones qui
parle de turquie voyez turkménistan axa
et qui arrive à
oulchy enfin dans le think tank donc ce
sont des musulmans et ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que effectivement il ya
eu des attentats et que les chinois donc
se sont mis dans une logique de
protection contre ce qu'ils appellent
les djihadistes oui bourbon
il ya eu des attentats ça c'est sûr
maintenant voilà donc c'est clair que
comme pour le tibet comme
pour les ouigours là les chinois
contrôlent la population sacrifices pour
eux ou c'est simplement eu un mal
nécessaire s'ils considèrent les
ouigours les tibétains comme comme des
sushis noah il faut les partis comme des
bêtes
pas du tout qu'ils soient dans cette
logique là
voilà nous je comprends que ça nous
choque un
bon mois ce que j'ai vues si vous voulez
de loi c'est effectivement ce sont des
sortes de prison
voilà maintenant je suis pas rentré
dedans et je ne peux que me fier si vous
voulez à au reportage de certains
journalistes qui est sûre quand même
faut le savoir c'est que les chinois si
vous voulez attribuer un peu toutes ses
montées c'est monté médiatique sur le
tibet sur hong kong sur les ouigours à
une volonté américaine de les
déstabiliser vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
du couple où ils ont des preuves
disons que si vous voulez c'est clair
aujourd'hui le pays bas le pib chinois
est grosso de la 14 mille milliards de
dollars les américains sont à 20000 et
tourne à 7 % d'après la règle en
économie des 70 60 / 7 1 s'est un peu
moins de sept mois face à on dit ça fait
dix ans donc dans dix ans ils auront
doublé ce qui veut dire voyez 114 dans
dix ans ils seront à 28 les américains
aussi vont grimper ils sont à 20 donc le
dépassement est pour bientôt donc on
voit bien si vous voulez que les
américains à mon avis tente le tout pour
le tout pour essayer essayer de
préserver leur suprématie mondiale on
voit bien que trump s'énerve un peu bon
plus que ça d'ailleurs et je pense
crédible moi le fait que effectivement
les américains cherchent par tous les
moyens à bons maintenant ça veut pas
dire que la situation est acceptable
mais attention voilà ce que je veux dire
quand même c'est que et là je reviens ce
que vous disiez sur l'opium
là j'ai donc j'ai passé quatre semaines
en chine j'y vais quand même faut le
savoir entre une et trois fois par an
quand on commença à bord des voiliers à
faire du prêchi prêcha que je comprends
un mois en tant qu'européen je suis tout
à fait du côté de ceux qui effectivement
sont choqués mais il faut être prudent
parce que les chinois aujourd'hui vous
dise quand on les pousse ils vous disent
bon attendez attendez les occidentaux
n'oubliez quand même pas que c'est
d'abord vous qui avait introduit
effectivement le pire dans chine après
les deux guerres d'opium c'est quand
même vous qui avez lancé de bombe
atomique sur nagasaki et hiroshima donc
entre 2 200 300 mille morts c'est quand
même vous qui avez massifier la traite
négrière souley en afrique entre 11 et
15 mille victimes c'est quand même vous
pardon entre 11 et 15 mille victimes des
1000 ou non melior oui entre merci oui
millions de victimes c'est quand même
vous qui avait exécuté froidement cinq à
six millions de juifs c'est quand même
vous qu'ils occidentaux plaisir dérange
pas les autres sont au choix pas des
français les occidentaux c'est quand
même vous qui
avait eu je crois 20 millions dans la
première guerre mondiale c'est quand
même vous qui avez eu entre
50 et 80 70 millions de morts deuxième
guerre mondiale donc si vous voulez
quelque part quand on leur dit sa
légitimité après quand on leur dit mais
c'est quand même vous avec votre réforme
agraire qui avait poussé lagacé alors
c'est ce que je leur dis le grand bond
en avant
quel prix voilà exactement là le grand
bond en avant la révolution culturelle
etc alors eu dix reconnaissent 30
millions de morts nous ont dit de 40 bon
dans cette je dirais comptabilité
macabre si vous voulez j'ai fait cette
comptabilité et si on pousse les feux
très loin cyr cyan on rajoute tous les
camps du travail les laogaï chinois bon
on peut arriver à 70 millions de morts
baissé à mon avis énorme mais nous
occidentaux d'état sans donc
malheureusement je dirais que si on fait
cette comptabilité macabre des morts bah
on n'est pas forcément bien placé après
effectivement faut regarder au niveau
légitimité et c'est pour ça que c'est un
grand débat et que à ce jeu là je suis
pas sûr qu'on soit qu'on soit gagnant en
terran
ouais on appelle ça la technique de la
plage c'est ça au lieu au lieu d'envoyer
un seul agent vider la plage avec un
gros camion on envoie un million ils
prennent pas de sots et en fait on
laisse coup quand il rentre à la maison
et on récupère grain de sable par grain
de sable alors je vais vous dire c'est
intéressant vous posez la question
finalement de quelque part d'espionnage
l'intelligence économique extra prend
alors les choses ont beaucoup changé ce
que valent danse est devenue très simple
dans mes cours j'ai cinq programmes bon
j'ai des étudiants qui sont de toutes
nationalités léger surtout des chinois
et si je demande alors je ne citerai pas
le nom de la société peu importe les
sociétés occidentales quand je demande à
des étudiants en occident des étudiants
chinois travaillant dans les sociétés
occidentales si quelqu'un du parti
communiste chinois vous demande de lui
transmettre des informations
confidentielles de votre société est ce
que voulait transmettez ou pas je peux
vous dire que quand je pose la question
à mes enfants gs pratiquement 1 100 % de
chinois qui lave là bas et qui me disent
bien sûr j'allais les impôts faut savoir
d'ailleurs parce que ça moi je les ai
appris récemment que depuis 2010 est
c'est obligatoire c'est à dire que les
n'importe quel chinois travaillant dans
une société en chine prime industries
occidentales si les démarchés par
quelqu'un qui lui demande de transmettre
l'information maintenant c'est
obligatoire de même que en cyber
n'importe quelle société l'état peut
récupérer les datas de n'importe quelle
société travaille en chine voilà alors
donc sous la coupe court à toutes les
techniques gelé d'espionnage et
maintenant c'est devenu obligatoire et
c'est ça lorsque je m'amuse moi avec mes
études en france est donc dans le même
temps si j'ai des étudiants français
j'ai des étudiants chinois donc les
étudiants chinois à 100% me dise pas de
problème si on me demande de transmettre
les informations je les transmets côté
français je pose la même question donc à
des français qui sont là qui sont
souvent en exergue mbiye donc qu'ils
sont des personnes qui ont entre 35 et
50 ans qui ont des responsabilités je le
redis vous travaillez vaillant vous
travaillez chez huawei chez zte et ch et
alibaba et puis le ministère l'industrie
français vient vous demander des
informations des données sur votre
société chinoise a est ce que vous les
donner ou pas
pratiquement aucun français donne les
infos donc voyez déjà il ya un énorme
décalage bon et ça je pourrais aller
encore plus loin c'est qu'effectivement
haut niveau au niveau 2 de l'espionnage
mais on leur a ouvert les mains on leur
a ouvert les bras on a tout ouvert alors
les chinois on était mal à nos efforts
pour quoi être côté français qu'on a on
a tout fait pour leur faciliter le
travail malheureusement bon
des exemples alors déjà au niveau
stratégique nommé au niveau stratégique
les chinois ont bien avant tout le monde
compris que c'était le pouvoir
technologique était important pouvoir
tech universitaires scientifiques
technologiques dont ils ont mis le
paquet sur les labos les centres de
recherche des professeurs et tard parce
qu'il distille et finalement ils ont
raison c'est le sait le pouvoir
technologique qui donne poids économique
qui donne le poids militaire qui donne
le pouvoir politique est là où
finalement ou d'autres les attendait sur
d'autres terrains
les chinois ils ont avec patience temps
et là c'est la plage ils ont envoyé
beaucoup de gens partout des
scientifiques etc et ils ont récupéré
mais très facilement puisque tout était
ouvert donc
votre espionnage français s'est réveillé
un peu tard non
est ce que ce seront eux qui sont
réveillés tas ou est ce que ce sont les
politiques moi je pense que si vous
voulez la conscience elle et elle allait
beaucoup de ministères opérationnel
était conscient d'un certain nombre de
menaces maintenant c'est aussi une
affaire de moyens c'est aussi une
affaire de 2
l'orientation est ce qu'on oriente les
personnes dans cette direction là ou pas
voilà non je pense que malheureusement
malheureusement c'est une responsabilité
partagée j'irai même ce qui est
dramatique
ce qui est dramatique c'est que
j'ai pu constater que beaucoup
d'européens aux occidentaux avaient
tendance à vendre vendre
lorsque les secrets d'affaires de leur
entreprise alors sur les ça se passe
maintenant c'est presque officiel
c'est bien fait je dirais que ça passe
par des spécialistes
souvent anglo saxons qui organise si
vous voulez avec des personnes à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise des
entretiens rémunérés et au mieux la
personne est consciente au mieux ou pire
plutôt consciente des informations
qu'elle vend et elle touche sur des
paradis fiscaux de l'argent je connais
les gens qui font ça d'accord au mieux
pour la personne pour la moralité de la
personne elle parle sans ça rende compte
parce que maintenant vous avez des
techniques qui sont très habiles que
derrière j'enseigne si voulez vous
pouvez récupérer beaucoup d'informations
sans poser de questions ce qu'on appelle
les techniques daily cité choix et les
chinois là dessus je vous dire je fais
moi-même en ange en chine je fais des
exercices entre français et chinois
ecsta les chinois sont très très habile
enfin pas que les choix et les
asiatiques vous aussi par exemple je
veux savoir si vous aimez tel bière ben
je vous dire sky aimez-vous tel bière je
vous pose la question vous répondre
voilà mais les asiatiques vont vous dire
le drame dans cette technique
d'acquisition de l'information c'est que
quand vous me posez une question vous
dévoiler une attention donc les chinois
eux ont développé des modes
d'acquisition de l'information sur de
l'implicite en se disant si ne c'est pas
que je cherche c'est l'info il ne pourra
l'y me mentir ni caché dissimulé congrès
parce que très naturellement les choses
qui vous disent poser une question c'est
risqué d'avoir un mensonge ou des
billets donc eu depuis ces militaires
ont développé des techniques
d'acquisition et quand je fais certains
exercices en amphi en cours etc chengdu
sharga et c'est très intéressant j'aime
bien monter des équipes chinoises si
vous voulez
avec cibles françaises
mon dernier exercice cinq chinoises
que j'ai pris dans l'amphi comme ça
pardon cette chinoise cette chinoise et
cinq français
elles ont fait un 100 %
100 % de bonnes réponses et les autres
n'ont rien vu puisque les autres les
cibles ont pour mission l de savoir
d'essayer de deviner ce que veulent
trouver ce qu'on appelle les lycées deux
mois et donc la voyez c'est ça là dessus
on a aussi du retard sur ces techniques
là bon en cyber gens parlent pas bon là
les chinois sont là sont en avance et
aujourd'hui quand on parle par exemple
de la 5g
je pense que pour nous français je vais
être un peu sec la 4g toujours pas enfin
il ya encore des endroits en france où
elle est pas mise donc pas installé mais
je pense que pour nous malheureusement
pour la 5g les chinois ils sont déjà
passés les suisses aussi américains les
anglais bon mais les chinois viennent de
se lancer la 5g sur cinq villes sur 50
villes pardon j'ai l'impression que nous
devons surtout ce qui est big date extra
on va devoir jouer un peu où l'un ou
l'autre on va se retrouver à si vous
voulez à être un peu au milieu et armé
par arbitrer mais à jouer soit l'un
contre l'autre voilà voilà on va être
mais c'est quoi votre position un peu
cela c'est quoi votre position par
rapport à la viabilité de la france dans
le 21e siècle en termes de valeurs
françaises en terme de liberté en termes
de business est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous pensez
c'est ma question
et fait le break est fait attention on
va pouvoir résumer ça trial mans on
n'est pas devenu tour s'est pas reposé
trop sur nos lauriers pendant des
décennies on n'a pas mis une classe
élite une élite qui complètement
rantanplan qui ne sait qu colporter le
ronron bien lénifiants et rassurant et
est ce que notre retard on est on est
tellement cuit qu'on ne pourra pas faire
l'effort de ces langues officielles
chinoises parce que ben culturellement
parlant ça va mal se passer on voit bien
ce qui se passe avec la mondialisation
et les gilet jaune en première ligne de
la mondialisation est-ce que c'est pas
trop tard je veux dire merci pour votre
question c'est pour ça que je suis
devenu professeur parce que enfin un
moment donné j'avais envie justement
comment lire 2
de réveiller un peu nos jeunes et puis
de fabriquer afin entre guillemets des
combattants sous les oueds et des
personnes qui vont se battre parce que
quand j'étais directeur export directeur
des achats fusions acquisitions moi
j'étais un premières tranchées et j'ai
été frappé de voir que derrière les gens
savaient pas trop ce que l'on faisait et
je vous dis alors certains évoquent avec
le nom que j'ai c'est à la bourde ayant
c'est à la sita liane foly ans et
français je suis très fier de mon trait
d'union donc je suis profondément
européen
on pourrait dire l'europe l'europe c'est
une solution oui enfin
intellectuellement oui mais le problème
c'est que si c'est l'europe de 27 ou 28
faible ça va pas aller sur les faces à 1
milliards 4,2 chinois est donc ce qu'il
faut c'est déjà que chacun devienne
vraiment fort comme je le dis souvent à
mes étudiants si vous mettez 30
unijambiste face à quinze sud africain
au rugby bon bah écoutez les quinze sud
africain vont quand même l'emporter bon
parce que ce qui compte c'est pas
tellement le nom en basset c'est la
force bon et là ce qu'il faut que nous
on arrive sous les a
c'est difficile à pour s'accuser les
chinois sont conquérants mais ils le
sont vraiment l'europe pour eux c'est
rien c'est je le dis assez c'est pas une
menace quand je me présente moi en fait
quand je parle d' emmanuel macron il ne
savait même pas qui c'est non mais je
plaisante pas à shanghaï oui mais à
chengdu safa qui s'est par contre
jacques chirac qui connaissent
oui ils ont un petit peu mais pour
l'instant ce qu'il connaît surtout ceux
dont ils m'ont tous parlent y compris
les chauffeurs de bus et tout c'est
surtout les gilet jaune en fait fort
c'est voilà ça c'est ça qui voit bon et
l'europe n'ont eux ils ont en eux ils
ont en ligne de mire les etats unis ces
voix-là états unis et quand j'étais à
chengdu au 70e anniversaire de la
révolution chinoise donc il ya quelques
semaines j'étais dans un hôtel et bon
j'attendais que ça se passe où les pour
faire mes prochains cours souhaitait des
jours fériés et là j'ai eu plein de
mails d'amis qui m'ont dit christophe
j'espère que les chinois vont comprendre
qu'ils sont là très arrogant que
hong kong
ça va pas que leur taux de croissance et
a63 et c'est bon donc moi je me suis
voilà je me suis mêlé à tous et toutes
ces familles chinoises qui qui est
déjeuner dîner etc qui chaque fois
j'essaie de prendre de chaque fois des
personnes qui parlaient anglais et je
voyais bien que j'avais à refaire les
conquérants des gladiateurs sur les
haies des gens et leur leur vision
c'était
la chine porte et la chine au numéro 1
au numéro un mondial et que l'europe
quand je leur parle de l'europe déjà je
vais fako france y voyait à peu près où
c'était à peu près la population alors
sans rien du tout quand je rencontre des
parents d'étudiants que j'ai en chine d
g par an chinois
chaque fois ils me disent facois la
population sait combien de personnes a
aujourd'hui ses 67 bon alors quand je
suis à chongqing il me dit 67 bon c'est
deux fois la ville quoi finalement bon
quand il parle de l'italie ils n'osent
pas le faire pour moi devant moi parce
que je fais ils veulent pas que je perde
la face mais il parle de l'italie même
population que la france comme d'un état
confetti voilà donc oui il faut se
regrouper mais il ya une vraie
révolution non pas la faire un chez nous
dans chaque pays pour
je dirais redevenir des des combattants
dans le domaine économique dans le
domaine technologique etc et je pense
que voilà on a 25 30 années qui si on
veut si on veut mais ce sera difficile
les chinois ils sont arrivés quand on
voit en trente ans ils sont arrivés à
décoller pourquoi est ce que nous on
n'avait pas la même chose parce qu'on a
des normes environnementales parce que
oui oui j'ai l'accord de trouver les
voies comme les chinois font on est
prisonnier de la sambre de de normes etc
et effectivement on étouffe on étouffe
l'initiative moi je donne un exemple il
ya trois ans à shanghai
donc je j'ai accueilli une
délégation de voile à de hauts
fonctionnaires français etc et j'avais
organisé une rencontre avec cette jeune
qui ont monté des boîtes des français
qui ont monté les boîtes là-bas et tous
avaient monté d'abord les six français
et un belge avait monté des boîtes ici
en europe ils avaient tous fermés et
puis la balle et ça marche et non quand
j ça marche et ça a marché très bien il
y en a même un qui ouvrait son 50e
magasin est toujours en exportation de
produits européens vers la chine donc
ils travaillent ces sept jeunes
travaillent pour l'europe et un moment
donné je me souviens il ya un haut
fonctionnaire qui s'est un peu énervé et
qui a dit à ses sept jeunes mais enfin
pourquoi montrer société on sent les
soutiens en chine venait faire ça en
france c'est tout la chine tapis
compliqué chinois c'est ceci c'est cela
mais pourquoi est on la laisse est à
l'unisson des mêmes mais monsieur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est en chine mais
parce qu'on gagne de l'argent
en france où malgré un mois du smic au
bout de 5 6 ans s'en sortait pas on a
fermé on est parti
voilà
mon thermos qu'on terme de change un peu
de sujet le système de surveillance qui
était très décrié en france et qui on
est en train d'ailleurs de copies
de reconnaissance faciale de notes
social par point d'attitude commencé
perçu la main alors
je veux dire et dieu sait que tous les
français partent avec il ya 170 millions
de caméras intelligentes ont beaucoup de
français partent avec l'idée de dire on
va secouer ces chinois parce qu'il faut
les leur ouvre les yeux et settat et à
notre grande surprise les chellois bouge
pas quand j bougent pas ils bougent pas
c'en est même au point où au bout de
alors à shanghai s'ils voulaient les
gens vous disent oui mais finalement le
bon côté de tout ça c'est au niveau
sécurité bon je vois mes étudiantes eux
donc des femmes vous disent ses bons
côtés de shanghai c'est qu'on se sent en
sécurité partout même la nuit bon j'ai
cette année l'année dernière j'ai un
étudiant qui avait laissé son
portable sur un banc public et c'était
un portable professionnel et deux heures
après il se rend compte et tout le monde
lui dit mathieu
malheureusement tu as dû te faire voler
je lui dit allez-y quand même parce que
tellement de caméras qu'avec un peu de
choses il le retrouvait
alors un autre exemple que je vous
donnais ça ça va vous amuser conscient
de la traque des activistes s'ils sont
conscients oui oui oui mais la perte de
liberté tout ça c'est un sacrifice oui
mais la liberté cc je suis là non mais
chut je suis tout à fait d'accord je
suis pas sûr que nous on accepterait ce
que les chinois acceptent avec leur
culture mais
donc ils le vivent très bien sans les
mêmes au point où
j'étais surpris là cette année j'ai une
personne quand même qu'à une quarantaine
d'années elle vient boire et elle me dit
mais les chinois je vais je me suis
demandé s'il plaisantait mais les
chinois rigole jus mais pourquoi on pose
cette question mais bien mais moi je
pensais en avant ainsi en exergue mvié
donc quelqu'un oui il dit mais je
pensais que c'était une telle prison
texte à
un autre exemple sur le big data
donc tu est à ciel ouvert peut-être
contrôlée par 90 88 millions du parti
communiste je vais vous dire alors là je
vais être un peu
provocateur là pour le coup
mais bon moi je me présente comme un
grand témoin généré honnête sincère bon
voilà pour ça que je veux pas je suis
pas un expert je suis pas un sinologue
je dis ce que je vois là
dire ce but
ça a sauté
gers de masse
bon ça va me revenir ça va me revenir
peu importe non ce que je voulais dire
sur le big data et qui va un peu dans le
sens que vous dites c'est que les
dernières on a fait une grande une
grande
table ronde si vous voulez avec des
chinois sur le big data et l'idée
c'était de vendredi mais présenter notre
rgp les voilà donc l'idée c'était de
entre gretz d'ouvrir les yeux des
chinois à la beauté du rgp les bons et
je vois votre sourire donc en fait la
personne qui a fait la présentation
c'est là aussi c'était quelqu'un de
d'expérimenter
on avait une centaine de chinois en face
de nous et on voyait bien que ce qu'elle
disait
les chinois se du mal à comprendre
moi ce que les temps la personne la plus
âgée 62 ans la prof est tous un peu les
techniques là bas il me dit christophe
vous avez beaucoup voyagé en chine vous
savez bien qu'en chine pas dans les
grandes villes mais dans les dents il
s'agit je confirme qu'il a raison mais
dans les campagnes de la petite ville
quand vous allez aux toilettes
il n'y a pas de mur
les femmes et les hommes sont séparés
mais les hommes voilà partage là
plusieurs buvettes et tout le monde
discute bon il me dit vous voyez en
matière de protection des données on n'a
pas du tout votre vision votre pudeur on
est un peu les uns sur les autres depuis
toujours on a 4 5 mètres carrés par
habitant depuis toujours dans les
grandes villes on est les uns sur les
autres une d une une des profs me dit
elle que bon bain elle dormait côtés de
ses parents ses parents ils sont à 1 m
bon et tout laisse tous les 2-3 soir son
père lui disait tu tourne la tête vers
le mur tudor et je veux pas t'entendre
jeu pas de voir bon et puis elle dit
maintenant que j'ai 60 ans je raconte
voilà bah je faisais semblant de dormir
puis j'entendais plein de choses et j'ai
compris quand j'étais je suis devenue
adolescente ce que ça voulait dire voilà
donc on est les uns sur les autres et
c'est vrai que en matière de protection
des données et ces bas j'ai bien vu que
les chinois il percutait pas au niveau
des
peut-être penser non bien sûr qu'ils ne
demandent pas dieu sait qu en cours dieu
oui voit ce que jouer lire ça et ça me
revient dieu sait qu en cours jose des
portes mais parfois l'attention lâcher
un peu provocateur mais comme je les
ressentis et je suis pas le profit le
seul professeur français à le ressentir
j'irai parfois sur certains sujets sur
certains sujets à 3,6 bien et dans
certains voient là pour certains cours
j'ai le sentiment d'être plus libre
dans mes paroles dans un amphi chinois
que dans un amphi français
libres dans quel sens bien dans le sens
où je contrôle mes paroles si vous
voulez beaucoup plus
dans le sens où voilà vous avez ainsi
nombre de choses taboues on le voit bien
comme quoi la plage justement c'est pour
ça que 3 300 exemplaires sky c'est pour
ça que je suis ravi justement d'aider
votre chaîne parce que on voit bien que
il ya des sujets il ya des personnes qui
n'ont pas la parole des sujets qui sont
un peu tabou brisé il ya des personnes
qui sont mises en dehors de l'espace
public et c'est là que ça bon donc il ya
certains sujets voilà en europe si bien
particulièrement en france où là qui
sont interdits sous les bons et où
certaines certaines prises de position
bah voilà bon et moi je suis quelqu'un
de très ouvert très mode ex mais en
chine on ne m'a jamais rien dit et même
sur hong kong je prends des sujets comme
la gestion d'internet quel regard
porte-t-il sur ce ski sur ce qu'il se
passe à hong kong combat merci pour la
question est alors sur hong kong je vais
vous dire j'ai été
moi je suis quelqu'un sous les qui me
méfie mais comme beaucoup de gens de
toutes les sources de tous les
intermédiaires donc j'aime bien avoir le
contact direct quand je peux
alors ça commence ça commence avec hong
kong ça commence avec mon propre fils
qui fait son voyage de noces là bas et
qui passe et qui revient en me disant je
lui dis alors à hong kong ils me disent
j'ai rien vu raji ben écoute alors c'est
peut-être le voyage de noces tu es midi
donc mais j'ai rien vu bon alors
j'appelle immédiatement j'ai quatre
étudiants qui font des stages là bas et
je leur dis alors sur hong kong monfils
n'a rien vu mais et vous alors sur les 4
3 3 qui mise mais moi j'ai rien vu avant
et il y en a un quatrième qui me d'ici
six mois j'ai vu mais je suis allé dans
le coin de causeway bay ou là
effectivement c'est assez localisé dans
le temps localisés dans l'espace et un
peu comme sur le mode d gilet jaune
finalement ou sur le mode du
du mouvement algérien cirque il ya des
endroits où c'est l'école polytechnique
en première ligne
pour les techniques ont conclu deux
cents personnes oui c'est à dire
qu'effectivement c'est un moment donné
c'est localisé bon alors ça veut pas
dire que le mouvement n'existe pas
question internet pourquoi dit il qu'il
ait de la chaîne qu'il que vous aidez la
chaîne bas parce que d'une certaine
manière en venant chez think herviou je
sais que la parole est libre voilà
et que revenons revenons à notre sujet
on va fermer la parenthèse chine vrai et
on va parler médias propagande
contre-propagande
ça vous fait quoi de voir maintenant au
jour d'aujourd'hui qui lie à l'idée de
créer un conseil supérieur d'éthique et
de déontologie du journalisme en france
à au niveau déontologie avait déjà
quelque chose mais assez libre
c'est
moi je suis sceptique c'est comme
d'encadrer les faits que yo c'est assez
difficile
je pense ça va ouvrir des débats infinis
je vois très bien lit je vois très bien
le lead et souley
bon je pense que si on peut déjà écarté
les situations fait tout ce qui est
mensonge et c'est bon là dessus à
propagande de guerre proprement là mais
le gros problème si vous voulez cesser
ce que j'appellerais le borderline
legris ouais je suis dit en greece donc
plus par hasard c'est à dire le nom faux
le problème c'est parlons du nom faut
souvent c'est une question je poserai
semblant alors ça peut être le vrai
semblant mais le nom fu le nom fu
comment peut-on être dans le nom fu
suffit de poser par exemple une question
après tout on peut si vous voulez dire
qu'un homme politique par exemple et
c'est faux je précise et pédophile si
vous dites c'est un pédophile ça c'est
de la calomnie
si vous dites serait-il pédophiles avec
un conditionnel ben vous ouvrez le débat
et finalement vous êtes plus ou moins
inattaquable après tout on a le droit de
poser la question voyez bon mais si vous
posez la question
si ensuite vous massifier ce genre de
questions sa part de partout à un moment
donné les personnes vont vous dire il
n'y a pas de fumée sans feu donc
forcément s'il ya des questions bayor
quelque chose et donc après vous ouvre
un débat finalement et
fait partie d'une stratégie pour ses
soins je peux enfin je pense que de plus
en plus sur les lunes des manipulations
qui marche le mieux aujourd'hui c'est
finalement c'est pas tellement le
mensonge c'est le soupçon c'est le doute
quand vous instiller le doute
quelque part si vous voulez vous arrivez
à avoir des effets où on peut pas
prouver vous avez tort voilà et vous
arrivez à avoir des effets qui peuvent
être un majeur avec associé avec les
réseaux sociaux par exemple si vous
voulez si vous prenez aujourd'hui dans
les élections
présidentielles ou oates avaient des
taux d'abstention en europe qui sont
énormes d'accord qui sont énormes et
aujourd'hui vous pouvez si vous avez un
en france et 40% je crois à la fois
dernière donc finalement pouvait être
élu mal élu finalement vous être mal élu
avec 30% donc comme si je reprends les
chinois qui disent que les élections
occidentales sont devenus un vrai jeu de
quilles si vous voulez où il s'agit plus
de faire tomber les quilles
que de promouvoir son propre candidat
donc le candidat gagnant c'est là qu'ils
castet droite dans ce jeu là où il faut
dégommer des qui si vous voulez c'est
sûr que le soupçon le doute peut être
peut être une arme dévastatrice et on
sait pas ce que moi je les calculs et
que un soupçon
bien orchestrée peut générer peut
impacter elle est entre 7 et 12 % de
personnes donc entre 7 et 12 % de
personnes quand vous jouez que sur 60 %
et que pour gagner il faut 30% ça peut
ça peut ça peut impacter et donc
l'avantagé entre guillemets la journée
des états qui font ça dans d'autres
états je peux alors ça c'est quelque
chose monsieur je pense que tout est
possible vous et la personne qui peut
enregistrer vous avez
des états qui peuvent effectivement du
lou biou des questions
hobby ça peut être des lobbys ça peut
être des etas à peu des personnes et ça
peut aussi vous avez le doute ou le
soupçon qui kiné j'ai de lui même voyez
qui est spontané bon et ça parfois
ces ravageurs ça c'est sûr pour ça que
je pense qu'il faut former moi c'est ce
que je fais avec mes propres étudiants
les former
a commandé à savoir dire je ne sais pas
c'est que dans mon cours je commence
toujours mes cours d'intelligence
économique
je forme mes étudiants à dire je ne sais
pas
et je sais que je ne sais pas et on part
chaque fois de cette situation là parce
que si vous voulez aujourd'hui comment
il ya deux manières de sortir du jeu ne
s'est pas soit ces jeux c'est donc là
c'est de la connaissance des faits des
réalités des démonstrations etc des
preuves soit c'est de la croyance mais
il faut être conscient quand on est dans
la croyance est alors la croyance peut
être positive la croyance peut aussi
préparer la connaissance elle peut
motiver les gens etc mais la croyance
peut être si vous voulez
peut être un moyen de manipulation et ce
que je veux dire c'est que les gars là
il ya où il ya un vrai problème de fond
d'ailleurs je fais parfois réfléchir mes
étudiants là dessus c'est quand on parle
du doute quelle est la frontière entre
le doute légitime du philosophe la
personne qui légitimement exerce son
esprit critique et le doute
conspirationnistes de la personne sous
les qui doute s'en douter d'elle-même
faim et qui est on n'en finit plus vous
voyez et et ça je fais beaucoup
travaillé mes étudiants là dessus pour
justement les amener à ce qu' ils
sachent dire je ne sais pas et
finalement quand on on parlait tous les
sujets oui gourcuff je pense là mais je
pourrais apprendre d'autres parce qu'on
a parlé avant mais sur d'autres sujets
finalement on n'y connaît rien et c'est
dès expiration tous les experts parfois
enfin les vrais experts monsieur après
il ya ceux qui trichent voilà il ya ceux
qui créent des faux profils des fautes
recommandations mais normalement un vrai
expert est quelqu'un qui sait dire je ne
sais pas normalement pour moi un bon
mais
si les humbles voilà mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est que la guerre en libye
avec la libye
s'est passé quand on a vu un autre
expert en ministre des affaires
étrangères bernard henri lévy oui
c'était un xp ou c'est un commentateur
c'est une très très bonne question
bah c'est pour moi c'est un écrivain si
vous laissez à spécialiser cercles
littéraires
c'est plutôt gérer un agent d'influencé
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de soul
aide de mettre en résonance un certain
nombre de
voilà de l'attention
voilà sur la libye quand on voit la
situation actuelle chaotique et ses
branches
sur la syrie la syrie c'est dramatique
je pense qu'il n'ya pas
absolument dramatique
j'ai beaucoup tourné en syrie beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
bon surtout avant les conflits
je me souviens d'avoir demandé j'ai
d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup d'amis syrien
qui voit là malheureusement maintenant
sont plus en syrie il est souvent ils
sont partis
moi ce qui me frappe et en syrie il ya
une vingtaine trentaine d'années c'était
le taux de croissance démographique de
la syrie et je me souviens je fais la
même chose en algérie et je leur disais
mais au taux de croissance démographique
que vous allez vous n'êtes pas un pays
quand même très riche comment allez vous
[Musique]
donner du boulot aux jeunes voilà d'ici
15 à 20 ans je voyais beaucoup de deux
syriens qui voulaient 8 10 12 jeunes a
vu quatre leurs enfants bon
moyenne
si suite sous les bons alors forcément
ça crée une pression démographique
énorme d'où la guerre du liban d'où
beaucoup de choses si vous voulez et do
ba voila malheureusement la guerre
civile entre guillemets ccc c'est triste
à dire mais remet ces mêmes pensées même
monstrueuse que jb remet les compteurs à
zéro entre guillemets voyez bon donc oui
non c'est dramatique c'est le gars en
syrie c'est dramatique ce qui s'est
passé en libye ça qu'on parle maintenant
non pas du printemps ramé de l'hiver
arabe et quand je vais en algérie ce que
je tourne aussi beaucoup en algérie où
je forme des étudiants
il ya un mouvement vous savez avec des
élections pour bientôt secondés on voit
un gros mouvement ce qui était longtemps
qu'on france oui mais ce qui est
intéressant parce que effectivement avec
les réseaux sociaux n'est enfin les
réseaux sociaux sont capables de mettre
beaucoup de gens dans la rue mais le
problème c'est d'arriver à transformer
cette colère si vous voulez en mouvement
politique ça c'est moins c'est moins sûr
hélas ce qui est intéressant en algérie
c'est de voir que les algériens parce
que mes propres étudiants me le disent
certains vont manifester sur les i me
disent
on veut
manifester notre colère mais on ne veut
pas d'actes de violence
claude pays parcs en cacahuètes comme sa
part en libye eux ont connu une très
dure entre 94 et 2001 l'année de la
concorde civile avec bouteflika donc
cette année extrêmement difficile et ils
ne veulent pas reconnaître recommencer
avec de telle ou telle période si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que moi j étais
1ère fois j'y étais c'était il ya
quelques mois et tous mes collègues
profs algerian disent eux-mêmes ils me
disais on va vers l'impasse on va vers
une certaine impasse parce que on n'a
pas la volonté fallait les algériens
n'ont pas la volonté de franchir un
certain seuil de violence
en face il de sa voix
là et effectivement c'est
on voit là les limites des réseaux
sociaux c'est que les réseaux sociaux
sont capables effectivement de m et
comment alors je suis pas en train de
pousser les algériens à je dirais aller
plus loin mais comment arriver à faire
en sorte que le peuple soit mieux
reconnue
pas facile voilà c'est pas facile et
réseaux sociaux
bon
donne un certain
certaines sont des coûts voilà chambre
d'écho à la colère mais quand on regarde
partout que ce soit au venezuela que ce
soit en algérie
pour l'instant hong kong
en france au liban et dans d'autres pays
on voit bien que finalement il ya yal
cette colère de la rue mais ensuite il
n'y a pas forcément de ce qu'est ce que
c'est est ce que je vais vous poser
cette question puis je vais aller ouvrir
un peu puisque vous avez entendu avec un
qui sonne jamais perdre au milieu des
impôts je vais vous poser une question
concernant l' instrumentalisation la
stimulation des révolutions arabes des
révolutions de jasmin des révolutions
oranges des révolutions de tout ce qu'on
veut il ya
ya ya
on entend dire qu'il ya de stimulation
dette extérieure on entend dire par
exemple en france que les russes sont
derrière les gilets jaunes on a entendu
que saigner les américains qui étaient
derrière la révolution orange nous a
entendu dire que derrière la révolution
égyptienne y avait eu
le petit kit de stimulation de tout ça
je vous lance sur cette question je vais
ouvrir la porte je regarde en 2030
la propagande de guerre le rôle des
journalistes dans la propagande bien
exemple non mais je pense que c'est
évident dire qu'une fois que c'est parti
je pense que la règle
jeu pour certains
agents c'est effectivement de mettre un
peu d'huile sur le feu bon et là que
certains leur soin de déclencher
disparaître ça c'est possible soit de
rajouter de l'huile sur le feu sage les
vues vingt mille fois quand un événement
par au niveau de la planète
vous avez d'ailleurs des gens qui sont
pas forcément des personnes qui ont
déclenché l'événement mais qui sont
simplement là pour
amplifié l'événement et là c'est clair
que dans tous ces révolutions oui il ya
des forcément des agents qui
confirme
voilà donc
[Musique]
alors sur le plan arabe
ce que je dirais c'est que
effectivement on est plutôt aujourd'hui
quand on fait le bilan dans une logique
[Musique]
divers arabe et
en tunisie ça se passe plutôt mieux
qu'ailleurs mais finalement il ya de
quoi être entre guillemets pour les
citoyens peut-être un peu déçu
je pense que
au niveau de nos démocraties
il faut voir aussi que nous mêmes on a
du mal moi je pense que quand je vois ce
qui se passe sur
l'europe
c'est bon
voilà retour donc
voilà donc j'avais dit oui je pense
qu'effectivement il ya un certain nombre
d'acteurs dans la guerre de
l'information qui rajoute qui mettent de
l'huile sur le feu quelles sont ces
acteurs est complètement évident ah ben
je pense ça peut être alors soit c'est
des états mais plus en plus de plus en
plus ce sont des acteurs privés des fins
d électrons libres des électrons libres
proche des états parce que les états
préfèrent éviter d'être entre guillemets
e
fait référence à la firme de troll
russes ou des choses comme ça oui ou
même si on prend par exemple
les israéliens les israéliens quand ils
peuvent mener certaines actions en
général ou les chinois c'est pareil les
les chinois ont vingt mille cyber
[Musique]
miliciens comme ils disent qu'ils sont
plus ou moins des privés 1 donc de plus
en plus si vous voulez les états essaye
de ne pas apparaître au grand jour donc
ils préfèrent rentrer sous traiter ça
joue le rôle de coups feu donc oui c'est
clair ça c'est sûr les journalistes dans
tout ça
parce que les journalistes sont victimes
de propagande est ce que les
journalistes sont victimes et cible de
propagande ce que les journalistes sont
quand les livres de les prendre c'est
comme les ong c'est difficile de les
prendre en bloc parce qu'il ya
journalistes et journalistes
autre constatation la presse moi je
pense que
[Musique]
je pense qu enfin le métier de
journaliste quand on discute avec
certains journalistes je vous dise je ne
suis pas sûr que le métier de
journaliste fan n'évolue pas dans les
années à venir et qui est même certains
pensent qu'il pourrait disparaître bon
moi je pense qu'on a quand même besoin
enfin la même sûrement besoin de
personnes qui
traitent avec des sources primaires
le font de façon professionnelle honnête
et je dirais jose 10
objectifs si vous voulez plus ou moins
objectives à charge et à décharge
on a besoin de ces personnes là bon
alors qu'après pour vous expliquer la
défiance bas
il ya eu tellement de
c'est là la presse à haïfa la presse
alors pas toutes les presses à c'est
pareil c'est surtout je pense certaine
presse audiovisuelle certaines chaînes
en continu qui ne joue pas le rôle
voyait d'informateurs
notre objectif et c'est où on sent que
derrière il ya un peu ce sont des
chaînes l'influencent donc elles vont
chercher à
promouvoir une idée pour mouvoir une
personne une société etc donc les gens
s'en lasse forcément un moment donné ils
perdent
en crédibilité et du coup le drame c'est
que quand on a plus confiance à un
moment donné on se fabrique sa propre
comme en rlp voilà sa propre réalité
c'est propre
croyances et finalement c'est pas bon
non plus bon finalement quand on va sur
internet que l'on peut voir c'est
beaucoup de gens
consolident leur intuition de départ en
fait souvent ils n'en savent rien et ils
consolident voilà mais comme comment on
fait pour vivre dans un monde mondialisé
où l'espace médiatique semble ne pas
remplir son rôle comment on fait quand
la population et au milieu de deux tirs
croisés de propagande de certains états
comment comment fut moi alors à titre
personnel à ce que je fais c'est bon
déjà comme je le disais mais c'est c'est
peut-être un aveu de faiblesse mais je
n'hésite pas à dire je ne sais pas voilà
donc alors c'est pas très satisfaisant
dans la mesure où
moi je me trompe pas sous l'écran et ça
m'évite de prendre parti trop vite
d'être manipulés et c'est bon
ensuite je pense que la technique
classique 1 c'est d'essayer mais on peut
pas le faire sur tout ça prend beaucoup
de temps c'est d'essayer d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle des données primaires des
sources primaires bon les sources
primaires c'est quand on a la chance de
les avoir
la technique c'est ensuite d'essayer
d'avoir des sources primaires à charge
et à décharge donc pour créer du
contradictoire ça c'est important et
puis éviter aussi de tomber dans la
simplification dans la caricature etc
voilà ça moi quand on fait des avec
ces étudiants quand on fait si vous
voulez on parle dossier compliqué et on
essaye d'établir la vérité ça nous prend
chaque fois en fait plusieurs jours
c'est minimum donc ces diffusions zanni
ses marques fois que je viens d'aller
bien sûr donc c'est extrêmement
difficile
extrêmement difficile et c'est vrai que
dans ce monde où l'information est
chaotique j'avais un peu c'est le
brouillard informationnel si vous voulez
ben je pense que souvent
le mieux c'est franchement c'est resté
sur la casse je ne sais pas et puis
d'essayer voix afin d'être prudent voyez
sur hong kong j'ai été très très prudent
voilà je suis prêt je préfère être
prudent
vous préférez plutôt parce que vous
travaillez là bas non non ça va pas du
tout encore parce que vous travaillez en
chine n'ont même pas parce que je suis a
envoyé par des français un bon donc j'ai
aucun problème moi ça fait trente paris
mais
on va parler des vidéos bombe ce que
vous appelez vidéo au monde et l'une des
vidéos capable de retourner une opinion
des vidéos capable de radicaliser les
gens des vidéos capable de faire penser
des gens à gauche ou à tout ça
récemment on a vu nos médias français
ont propagé des faits qui nous comme un
loup charnier de timisoara
comme les couveuses en irak comme ben
laden a tout un arsenal planqué dans une
montagne notamment aménagé avec un
camion et mytilène piscine on a vu
les militaires us faire pipi sur des
cadavres de ça c'est l'exemple que
j'avais donnée pour justement les vidéos
bombe donc effectivement en fait j'étais
parti
moi ce qui m'avait marqué dans cette
affaire des
américains qui urinait sur des talibans
c'est l'impact que cette vidéo une
simple vidéo avait eu sur
une personne un peu déséquilibré et
qu'elle avait transformé en criminel
alors j'étais partie du triangle du feu
alors tous les pompiers connaissent le
triangle du feu dire pour qui un feu il
faut que y est
[Musique]
de l'oxygène
un activateur d'énergie donc une
allumette et puis forcément à
combustible donc combustible comburant
activateur d'énergie donc
quand le feu est créé on peut rajouter
de l'huile sur le feu donc ça c'est
l'huile voilà donc j'avais imaginé sous
les l'idée d'un ce que j'appelle losange
du feu donc
le comburant l'oxygène le combustible le
bois l'activateur d'énergie l'allumette
et puis l'huile et quand j'ai regardé
s'ils voulaient toutes ces vidéos je me
suis dit tiens c'est drôle finalement
cet incendie médiatique
ça ressemble un peu au feu c'est à dire
que l'oxygène c'est quoi sont les
vapeurs inflammables
bon ben ce sont les tensions à l'époque
qui existait entre les occidentaux et
les musulmans donc il y avait un
contexte de haine donc à partir du
moment où effectivement il ya ce
contexte là n'importe quel brindille
peut déclencher l'explosion ce n'importe
quel est un sel peut déclencher
l'explosion donc ça c'est le comburant
c'est l'oxygène à la prayelle
combustible alors le combustible c'est
quoi c'est la vidéo
du sergent abe sylla qui urinent sur sur
les talibans et qui tourne cette vidéo à
la limite c'est peut-être pour lui rien
ne dit que mitigé l'un des moyens je
vois là je veux faire un whistleblower
derrière c'était un relanceur dallaire
peut-être sur la réalisation les
élections américaines on voit la tête
occupée à la limite ils loi il la garde
pour lui et il repart aux états unis
donc le combustible est là alors les
activateurs d'énergie c'est celui qui le
met sur internet donc peut-être que la
vidéo a circulé finalement parce qu'il
l'a passée à deux trois amis et c'est
que celui qui le met sur internet oublie
le fait que la vidéo
été faite par intel souley est donc lui
se dit bon battue après tout jamais sur
internet
[Musique]
e
voilà ça va déclencher quelque chose
effectivement ça déclenche quelque chose
et ensuite parce que le geste est abject
et avec là je dirais la vitesse la
viralisation sur l'internet
effectivement là la vidéo fait le tour
du monde en en quelques heures et
ensuite vous avez tout ce qui rajoute
finalement de l'huile sur le feu les
blogueurs assure le journal sexta et qui
font de cet incendie un incendie
planétaire qui a l'âme à un moment donné
finalement transforme une personne
ordinaire
en criminel puisque c'était déjà
criminelle de pisser sur des canards oui
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais là la
personne le musulman qui voit cette
vidéo c'est le viol d'un tabou pour lui
justement et donc ça le choc au dernier
degré et il décide malheureusement de
tuer je crois quatre ou cinq français
alors que
parce que lui confusément mélange
français américains pour lui c'est
occidentale et voilà et donc voilà
comment finalement la combinaison de ces
quatre ingrédients
transforme finalement 1 1
quelqu'un voit la normale en criminel
alors là est ce qu est ce qu on peut
faire le parallèle avec la vidéo
collatéral des matchs de wikileaks oui
vous vous rappelez de cette vidéo la
exactions depuis l'hélicoptère qui
massacre oui depuis un hélicoptère
avait est ce que est ce qu'on peut faire
le parallèle avec ça c'est une vidéo
bombe est ce que tu sais pas où c'est
pas un témoignage journalistique que de
montrer les exactions de l'armée qui
s'est projeté en effet quelque part
c'est vrai quelque part on a les mêmes
ingrédients
les mêmes ingrédients avec comme pour
les moeurs américain qui urinait chaque
fois une intentionnalité c'est à dire
qu'il ya quand même au départ et à
l'arrivée une intentionnalité ce que
j'avais voulu montrer dans l'article
vous signalez tout à l'heure c'est que
malheureusement la vidéo bombe peut se
mettre en route sans intentionnalité
c'est à dire que si on prend par exemple
un incendie effectivement vous prenez
dans la garrigue 2
marseillaise vous mettez
d'oxygène bayal l'oxygène vous mettez
des brindilles et plus lieu de mettre
une et à une une allumette craquer une
allumette vous mettez simplement un
morceau de verre
qui fait loupe il n'y a pas d'intention
nalité de quelqu'un qui veut allumer un
incendie mais à la fin finalement la
combinaison des trois déclenché
l'incendié déclenché des incendies c'est
à dire que on peut rentrer en guerre
avec ce genre de vie c'est à dire
qu'effectivement non mais c'est à dire
que vous avez la vidéo bombe
intentionnelle ou là on joue comme on
l'a dit avec tous ces 3 + 4 4e
ingrédients et puis vous avez le fait ou
là là ça se met en route tout seul c'est
à dire que vous avez 7 et personne ne se
connaissent pas ce qui est finalement
peu probablement le cas pour la vidéo
des marines américains quand même enfin
même si je disais il ya quand même su
l'aimer c'est vrai qu'au départ les
tensions que les musulmans les
occidentaux ben c'est pas le sergent
américain qui a filmé qui en est
responsable l'huile est responsable de
ça alors peut-être qu'il est responsable
de la mise en ligne est un sage hva
comment comment il voulait peut-être un
truc c'est lui qui l'a mis c'est
peut-être lui qui l'a mise en ligne ça
je ne sais pas reprenons de deux
exemples les charniers de timisoara
pouvoir a plus d'histoire bien sûr
c'était quoi l'histoire est bien c est
là où on la chute du mur
pour à ma connaissance pour salir je
crois le régime en place
on a essayé de faire croire que les
communistes roumains avaient
massacrer des
une population voilà timisoara les des
roumains en fait c'étaient des personnes
qui était sortie de la morgue voilà et
qu'on avait étalé dans stargate mais
l'idée c'était de faire croire qu'il y
avait eu un massacre voilà et donc c'est
simplement c'est pour
habiller
c'est de la propagande de guerre oui oui
complètement ça le les couveuses
irakienne c'est pareil ça c'est hill &
knowlton la société de communication
américaine proche de la cia qui avait
monté ce dossier en fait est là il avait
donc la jeune fille qui se prétend
infirmière
à c'était à koweït donc elle se prétend
des infirmières à koweit et elle
prétendait que à sa tombe de bébé avait
été
persée tués par des baïonnettes de
soldats irakiens et donc sa force entre
guillemets la force selon ce témoignage
c'est qu'elle pleure et elle s'adresse
au congrès elle arrive comme ça une
demi-journée à retourner l'opinion
publique américaine qui n'était pas
acquise encore à eau à l'idée que les
américains puissent intervenir à
pour libérer koweit donc c'est
effectivement le jeune homme était le
fils alors la liste est la fille de
l'ambassadeur du koweït aux états unis
donc c'est complètement une opération
montée un jeu complètement une opération
montée mais une fois que l'accord de
l'opinion publique afin que le congrès a
donné son accord après ça c'est éventé
et tout le monde a su que c'était une
affaire voit la montée fausses comment
les journalistes peuvent à éviter ça
c'est à dire propager la propagande de
guerre du gouvernement ba est ce que
c'est alors tout l'été dans ce qu'ils
perdent les journalistes qui jouent le
jeu bon
y en a eu
ensuite et
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup qui ont été
dupés un
mois je crois que dans cette affaire-là
vous avez quand même beaucoup de gens
qui
qui peuvent jouer le jeu enfin qui qui
peuvent se douter de quelque chose mais
qu'ils font rien voilà
certains journalistes voilà après vous
avez des gens et ce qu'ils dénoncent
mais après s'il est question aussi de
poids si vous avez un
seul être blogueur vous avais pas je
dirais une grosse audience bomba pouvez
le dire mais ça portera pas beaucoup à
la population elle fait comment vous
adaptez sein la population souvent elle
est manipulée
par qui par contre comment je dirais sur
la population elle a du mal à y voir
clair et elle suit voilà elle suit vous
savez je dirais même ce qui est terrible
en matière de manipulation de groupe
c'est que
la manipulation peut être
commandée
éthiques ok mais c'est à dire que vous
pouvez très bien
utiliser un son de grande cause si vous
voulez pour manipuler les gens par les
sentiments etc comme apporter la
démocratie à la veule ou fin à leur feu
l'un la petite fille voyez nous quand là
je reprends l'exemple parce que miser
chinois les chinois vous dise nous en
chine
on s'est beaucoup axé sur pour l'instant
sur la partie production donc c'est la
machine productive qui marchent à fond
et forcément beaucoup plus de recettes
donc après pour distribuer c'est plus
facile nous la machine productive marche
pas très bien et donc
beaucoup de groupes de pression france
etc en fait tu essayes de se brancher
sur la je dirais l'appareil de
redistribution pour essayer d'avoir plus
que les autres bons et la balle à vous
avez assemble de séquencer les gens
prend d'une si vous voulez qu'ils qui
marche bien malheureusement mais là je
vais être un peu monstrueux mais il faut
reconnaître que si vous laissez c'est
une technique qui peut fonctionner c'est
à dire sa technique de la victimisation
donc victimisation culpabilisation
demande de rédemption et réparation et à
ce jeu là vous avez effectivement une
compétition c'est assez terrible de dire
ça mais une compétition entre toutes les
communautés les groupes de personnes qui
se sentent victimes de quelque chose
mais si vous êtes victime n est pas
reconnue vous n'avez pas d'outil etc
vous ne serez pas vous ne pourrez pas
obtenir quoi que ce soit donc il ya une
vraie il ya un vrai savoir faire ce
qu'ils voulaient avec les médias avec
les ong éventuellement avec certains
avocats certains hommes politiques pour
porter certaines revendications et
essayer de comment dire d'obtenir
réparation quand vous êtes une victime
reconnue et là bas je dirais c'est c
c'est en europe on est dans cette est
court ce cette course si vous voulez un
petit peu la victimisation c'est
terrible de dire ça mais ça crée de la
division s'est pas toujours
étatique est ce que vous voyez de la
propagande et ça c'est la propagande
loyer de groupes de pression
est ce que vous voyez de l'art et de la
propagande sur notre territoire que ce
soit américaines russes
saoudienne auvergnate ou quoi que ce
soit
alors sur les gilles et jo garder dit la
propagande est ce que vous vous mettez
vous incluez tout ce qui est publicité
d'entreprise pas non priori non puis
c'est commercial non
mais il ya forcément une volonté de
comment dire de supprimer le libre
arbitre et je voulais dire alors
comment capturer des cerveaux l'idée
c'est comment arriver à capturer
mobiliser des cerveaux dont l'idée
l'idée est comment faire pour que la
population ne soient pas livrés alors à
toutes les propagandes à au 4e round
après round ce que voilà moi ce que je
dis à mes étudiants souligent je redonne
un peu les déterminants du comment être
un citoyen libre finalement je leur dis
vous savez la première étape il ya deux
étapes clés c'est un capturer les
cerveaux de les mobiliser la première
étape capturer les cerveaux
c'est gagner trois batailles finalement
la bataille des idées la bataille des
émotions la bataille des valeurs c'est
ce que les grecs oui j'avais inventé les
grecs appelé pathos enfin l'eau logos
pathos et os logos et tout ce qui est
bataille des idées donc là vous avez les
experts qui font face entre guillemets
aux communicants aux gens qui peuvent
parfois caricaturé aux gens qui
simplifie bon ça c'est la bataille des
idées
donc c'est parfois le slogan contre la
démonstration complexe bon vous avez la
bataille des émotions
bataille des sentiments ou là c'est
beaucoup la musique qui va jouer contre
c'est pas du texte de la musique se sont
c'est des images et au gaz et donc les
émotions c'est la petite fille qui
pleure devant le couvre la colère passée
par exemple voyez quand vous parle on
parlait tout à l'heure du koweit est
intéressant c'est que la jeune femme si
vos internautes vos amis l'avant sur
internet ils verront que la jeune femme
pleurait et donc c'est un grand voile à
et si vous dit quelque chose en pleurant
bah forcément ça rend plus impacte donc
pour beaucoup de gens on this il pleure
c'est que c'est vrai bon donc oui la
colère quand vous arrivez à faire en
sorte que la colère submerge la raison
si vous voulez vous
vous pouvez obtenir beaucoup plus
d'aider des gens alors ça peut être la
colère ça peut être la honte ça peut
être la joie ça peut être la peur donc
tout c'est tout c'est toutes ces
émotions sont sont importantes et sont
faciles à créer mois en cours si vous
voulez je demande à mes étudiants et ils
fabriquent des vidéos pour déclencher et
voiliers de la peur de la honte des
larmes explique très bien c'est assez
facile finalement de déclencher de
déclencher une émotion vous voyez les
formes et des spin doctor en puissance
non c'est non non parce que alors ils le
font les c'est pas tellement qu'ils sont
formés à ça c'est que il voit comme
c'est facile de le faire et que souley à
un moment donné ils se disent mais c'est
si facile qu'en définitive
il faut que je sois prudent ou prudente
parce que finalement je suis manipulable
j'ai moi beaucoup de vidéos si j'avais
le temps mais là j'ai pas le temps non
mais il faut les montrer et soul et pour
voir les vidéos que peuvent fabriquer
mes étudiants où ils peuvent sur les wii
déclenche une émotion c'est assez
impressionnant de voir
l'impact que peuvent avoir des jeunes
qui ont 19 20 21 ans 22 ans voilà et
c'est assez facile à faire alors
troisième grande bataille si on leur
donne le but de saison étincelant mais
non non non oui oui mais là là là ils
n'ont pas d'argent dans les exercices
qu'ils ont pas d'argent tous les houthis
et des outils gratuits sur le net et ils
ont gerald trois jours pour faire voilà
donc ils sont pas des spécialistes
arrive donc voyez la bataille des idées
bataille des émotions et puis dernière
chose à la taille des valeurs et dans la
bataille des valeurs dont classez vous
voyez partout c'est c
ça répond bas surtout valeur émotions
valeurs plus émotion les ong s'en sont
saisis souvent valeurs plus émotions
plus communication simple ou parfois
slogans et c'est bon et là vous arriver
finalement à capturer des cerveaux alors
ce que l'on voit au niveau des valeurs
si vous voulez c'est que de plus en plus
les personnes
en ont marre des mots voyez autant pour
la bataille des idées les mots sont
importants les mots l'épreuve autant sur
les émotions bon tout ce qui est image
et musique ok mais sur l'ailé tout ce
qui est bataille des valeurs les gens en
ont marre des mots ils veulent des actes
et ils disent bon
moins de mots plus d'actes maintenant
mais alors ça je le dis pour vos
internautes on voit entre les mots et
les actes on voit se développer quelque
chose d'intermédiaire ou en france
malheureusement on est je pense on abuse
c'est le symbole c'est à dire on joue à
fond du symbole du symbole du symbole
saint cirq ont fait croire que c'est un
acte mais en fait ce n'est pas un acte
oui et on va prétendre si vous voulez
soutenir un sombre de valeur par des
symboles bon pourquoi pas mais à un
moment donné la population demande plus
que des symboles elles demandent
vraiment des actes d actions dont vous
voyez cette première partie cette
première partie c'est important de
comprendre voilà que c'est ces trois
batailles l'a ensuite là vous avez
capturer des cerveaux mais vous les avez
pas mis en route vous avez question
d'internet est ce que vous avez lu la
stratégie du choc de naomi klein non
mais je retiens merci merci sky voilà et
merci l'internaute ensuite comment
mettre en comment mettre sous laisser
tous ces cerveaux en mouvement alors ça
c'est intéressant c'est comment
transformer quelqu'un qui a conscience
de quelque chose en personne qui bouge
alors là si vous voulez il ya un
ensemble de techniques qui sont
intéressantes et que l'on voit prospérer
partout alors j'irai quand vous allez en
tête ces trois grandes batailles
id émotions et valeur la technique la
plus utilisée aujourd'hui
parmi les plus utilisés cedex l'appel
extrait mise et c'est à dire qu'au
niveau des idées vous allez criminaliser
la personne que vous écoutez le
psychiatre ici ou là psychiatrisés au
niveau des émotions vous allez
hystériser les choses et au niveau des
valeurs vous allez excommunié donc à un
moment donné ce que je dis c'est à dire
vous allez sortir du champ un certain
nombre de personnes qui n'ont pas droit
au débat public voyez donc là c'est une
forme de c'est une forme de manipulation
alors vous allez donc ça c'est ce que
j'appelle tous qui extrait misez donc
vous poussez les curseurs à fond et au
lieu de dire par exemple au niveau
émotion au lieu de dire ben
c'est dangereux etc vous allez dire
c'est la fin du monde pas l'envoyer tout
tout devient extrême et là vous allez
pousser les gens à bouger en fait l'idée
c'est ça c'est en extrait misant un
certain nombre de paramètres pousser les
curseurs à fond si vous rajoutez un peu
d'urgence alors là les gens ils vont
bouger alors vous avez cette technique
là vous avez la technique aussi
simplement lors du de suivre avait
beaucoup de gens qui suivent et comme je
dis ce qui comme je vois le mimétisme
est souvent je le dis il est plus
confortable d'avoir il est plus
confortable d'avoir tort avec tout le
monde que raison contre tout le monde
quand vous avez tort avec tout le monde
personne ne vous dira rien à saouler
quand vous avez raison contre tout le
monde au départ les gens vont peut-être
mal le prendre parce qu'ils vont se dire
pourquoi il se singularise
et puis ensuite quand vous allez avoir
raison neuf fois sur dix voix les gens
vous en voudront peut-être un peu ou
beaucoup et donc alors vous avez le
suivisme vous avez tout ce qui est bâton
carottes aussi un associé à pour faire
bouger les gens voilà vous avez ensemble
de techniques qui sont importantes à
comprendre excommunié ckoi excommunié
c'est sortir du champ c'est-à-dire que
vous sortez la personne du champ du
débat public voilà elle est exclue parce
que elle est considéré comme
dans écoutable
contre-productif de faire ça à bas
oui je pense que oui au niveau
démocratique oui moi je suis choquée
mais on le voit bien oui là je veux pas
donner de noms mais on voit bien
certaines émissions
télévision dans les pays occidentaux
démocratiques strauss visiblement saoul
et on excommunie un certain nombre de
personnes qui n'ont plus voix au
chapitre plus rien et puis du coup en
fait le débat démocratique devient voilà
frelaté entre guillemets loyer et ça
faut reconnaître que
d'un autre démocratie nos démocraties
sont aussi imparfaite pour ça parce que
les chambres de maccarthysme de poser ou
oui alors le terme est un peu fort mais
oui en tout cas si on n'y prend pas
garde ça nous guette ça c'est sûr sûr
sûr sûr alors après il ya un autre débat
qui est important
ça c'est très intéressant je me suis
beaucoup intéressé si vous voulez sache
pas ce plan se passionnera vos
internautes sur
l'activisme
alors en course ou les jeux présentent
souvent le blanc le gris le noir le
blanc c'est ce que j'appelle le légal le
noir c'est d'illégal et le gris le nom
illégal alors vous avez d'un côté dans
le blanc donc tout ce qui est
parfaitement légal et militants dans le
noir parfaitement illégal les
terroristes et dans ce fameux gris
borderline les activistes alors pourquoi
et les activistes prospère aujourd'hui
et comment ça fonctionne lorsqu'on est
intéressant c'est de voir que les
militants eux par définition ne veulent
pas utiliser des moyens légaux par
définition donc ils vous diront
justement nous c'est la bataille des
idées la bataille des émotions la
bataille des valeurs voilà et on essaye
de gagner comme ça militants politiques
très bien mais
les activistes ont leur dire écoutez
c'est bien mais en fait je n'avais pas
beaucoup d'impact et c'est un peu bla
bla bla bla bla bla donc comment faire
pour avoir de l'impact alors l'autre
côté vous avez terroristes les
terroristes eux ils ont ils défendent
aussi des grandes causes comme les
militants les activistes et que ça mais
les terroristes eux sont franchement
dans l'illégalité puisque il n'hésite
pas à tuer et à détruire mais peut vous
diront c'est pas un problème entre
guillemets je le défends pas mais ce
qu'ils vous disent puisque soit on veut
changer de système
souvent ça on veut changer le système et
on n'a pas peur de discréditer notre
cause puisque finalement on veut choquer
on veut
choquer un grand coup et puis changer de
système donc la violence nous va très
bien alors les activistes qui est
intéressant c'est de comprendre comment
les activistes donc ça les activistes le
plus connu dans la littérature c'est
robin des bois qui détrousse et des
riches pour leur donner aux pauvres j
bien c'est intéressant de comprendre ce
qu'ils faisaient s'il avait que des
trousses et des riches soir était un
délinquant mais détrousser des riches
pour donner aux pauvres et relativise
c'est quoi si vous voulez c'est
quelqu'un qui va toujours entre
guillemets braver la loi
braver l'illégalité
mais qui va couvrir son illégalité par
définition non violente dont qui pourra
détruire des biens des parcelles ogm des
laboratoires etc pour le bien-être
animal donc il va braver la loi il va
être vraiment la frontière de
l'illégalité
et il va couvrir cette transgression par
une légitimité qu'elle a excusé de la
grande cause supérieure à la
transgression
et c'est s'être se
mêla enjouaillez de la transgression
aida légitimité supérieure qui fait en
fait la force de l'activisme aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que alors c'est par
exemple désobéissance civile ou actions
coup de poing vous avez aujourd'hui des
gens qui sont formés en désobéissance
civile et les personnes sont formées en
opération coup de poing c'est toujours
la même chose opération coup de poing ça
veut dire ces opérations coup de poing
on ne tue pas mais on secoue voyez bon
et donc on va
aller dans l'illégalité pourquoi parce
que si vous êtes dans l'illégalité
vous allez vous retrouver avec des
hommes politiques qui ont intervenir des
médias des forces de sécurité donc vous
allez avoir sous une couverture qui va
favoriser votre votre dialogue voyez
votre votre cause entre guillemets et
vous aller couvrir tout ça par une
communication pour expliquer voyez alors
ça on le voit partout partout maintenant
on voit bien qu'un système de
si vous voulez juridique flanche
je pourrais prendre et gilet jaune je
pourrais prendre toutes les grandes
causes aujourd'hui système je dis que
j'ai jaune il a été un oui mais quand je
vois l'arbre à c'est à dire que oui mais
je suis d'accord avec vous mais
systématiquement voyez les soul appelle
les activistes ou ceux qui se mettent
dans une position d'activistes en fait
vont
contredire
l'illégalité de leur action
par légitimité supérieure soutenu par
une grosse communication c'est qu'on a
fait la révolution française non mais il
ya beaucoup de révolutions qui ont été
faites comme ça mais à regarder pour des
shs travaillé à un moment donné sur
l'âge c'est pas des activistes non de
tech c'est justement c'est pas les actes
mais ils ont bien compris le système
voyez la combinaison entre guillemets
illégalité légitimité parce que même je
fais péter des gens mais en contrepartie
un jour houston tx de d'un secours oui
mais victor la légitimité il l'a trouvé
dans je ne suis pas une entre guillemets
un criminel je suis un combattant
regardez ce qu'ils font face à la télé
cassis et donc ce qui est intéressant de
comprendre c'est qu'aujourd'hui notre
système démocratique en souffre beaucoup
je pense qu'il ya un vrai vrai problème
là entre les combats si vous voulez
entre
légalité
illégalité ça c'est plutôt le domaine du
tribunal judiciaire et légitimité
illégitimité là on est plutôt dans le
tribunal médiatique mes enfants et ça
aujourd'hui l'expression à l'égaler
légal c'est ça oui oui aussi mais ça
c'est un vrai à mon avis c'est un vrai
défi pour nos démocraties pour les
années à venir c'est comment gérer si
vous voulez là
la légitimité d'un certain nombre de
groupes de pression de citoyens qui
veulent se faire entendre en fait et qui
vont se faire entendre en bravant la loi
et en délibérément transgressant la loi
pour se faire entendre et pour la
couvrir parce qu'en fait ils ne sont pas
entendus c'est ça qui est terrible c'est
que quelque part il estime qu'ils ne
sont pas entendus donc il arrive à ces
extrémités et du coup il a sacré un
espèce de si vous voulez de de chaos au
niveau juridique où finalement on sait
plus très bien
finalement si c'est légal illégal
légitime illégitime et ça quand j'en
parle avec mes collègues
professeurs chignon extérieur d'entre
eux mais ils n'ont pas ce problème là
puisque le problème est assez vite réglé
ils le reconnaissent
puisque l'état est partout enfin le
l'état est partout et les tous ces
groupes de pression malheureusement moi
je pense n'ont pas voix au chapitre
j'ai retrouvé ma question tout à l'heure
comment se construire une représentation
du monde et interagir avec lui où
l'information est instrumentalisé
question
[Rires]
que l'information soit astra
instrumentalisée c'est complètement
évident d'ailleurs dans une
dans une
vidéo et
qui est sur internet qui s'appelle
intervention christophe talla bourdillon
je cite justement je me souviens d'un
voyage que j'avais fait en finlande je
partais en finlande et j'étais assise
par hasard à côté d'une d'une
présentatrice météo vraiment par hasard
de la télévision et
j'ai été amené à m'adresser elle parce
que les autres tests pensant que j'étais
son mari m'avait apporté du champagne à
un moment donné j'ai demandé pourquoi
j'avais dû coupe de champagne à côté de
cette personne et c'est elle qui m'a dit
mais je suis présentatrice pète octobre
et alors là je lui avais dit je me
souviens je lui avais dit à balard vous
au moins parce qu'on est bon forcément
dans l'avion on en discute on sympathise
un peu et je lui ai dit alors vous au
moins dans la dans la formation météo au
moins vous dites que vous voulez abadie
vous rigolez n'ont pas dit non mais je
suis pas du tout ce que je veux si je
commence à dire que les stations n'ont
pas donné
non mais je me fais appeler etc j'ai
beaucoup de problèmes donc non je suis
obligé aussi même en météo de
de faire attention à ce que je dis est
quelque part
de
d'instrumentaliser la formation donc
c'est clair l'information non mais
laisse le mentaliser partout et donc à
partir de là faut pas rêver hein
c'est à nous de nous former et je pense
qu'il faut pas être de lapins de six
semaines et c'est là il faut former les
étudiants les aguerrir pour qu'ils ne
reçoivent pas comme une éponge
d'information comme ça il faut qu'ils la
mettent en doute et tant qu'ils n'en
sont pas sur genêt qui sache rester sur
la case je ne sais pas si ça qu'il me
semble essentiel c'est savoir rester sur
laquelle je ne sais pas et ce serait
tellement bien je pense y beaucoup de
gens savent est resté sur laquelle je ne
sais pas sincèrement vous avez vous en
tête vous des types de professionnels je
pense d'ailleurs nous français je vais
vous dire je pense que on est souvent
citée par pas mal d'étrangers
qui ont un peu tendance à tchatcher pour
tout et pour rien bon on se retrouve
entre nous mais c'est vrai que dans
d'autres je vois dans d'autres
professions enfin d'autres pays pardon
les gens n'hésitent pas à dire je ne
sais pas voilà bon mais je vais pas
nommer qui que ce soit mais analystes
une qualité vous savez de savoir dire je
ne sais pas comme on dit le silence et
d'argent la parole est d'argent et le
silence est d'or je pense que georges
boutet non non non non mais parce que là
on devra ainsi se laroquais un pas
compris une
autre question wikipedia c'est bien
c'est pas bien alors merci pour la
question moi je suis passé par plusieurs
stades premier pendant longtemps j'ai
dit c'est pas bon et c'est maintenant je
dis c'est bon il faut savoir utiliser
alors l'utiliser comment déjà sur la
colonne de gauche vous avez beaucoup de
langues c'est intéressant parce qu'on se
rend compte que
ce qui est par exemple en anglais n'est
pas la traduction ce qui est en france
est un exemple par exemple dans le
domaine du ciment dans le domaine du
ciment l'inventeur du ciment pour les
français c'est louis vicat pour les
anglais ces apps dean donc déjà vous
rendez compte qu'il ya un décalage entre
les deux donc c'est intéressant de voir
ça parce que vous dis tiens
il ya peut-être matière à creuser après
un deuxième point qui est intéressant
sur wikipédia c'est toutes les sources
et moi je suis très très source et
entendu sur ce primaire données
primaires et donc ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas tellement de de lire
finalement ce qui est sur wikipédia bien
sûr c'est intéressant c'est un point de
départ avant que c'est d'identifier les
sources de savoir où la personne
l'article comment il s'est nourri et
tout historien vous dira ce qui est
important c'est d'aller aux sources
primaires bombe à wikipedia permet
d'identifier un stock de sources
primaires et ça
on allait s'effacer même essentiel et
puis troisième point portant sur
wikipédia qui est intéressant vous allez
sûrement utiliser parce que je suis sûr
de votre communauté utilise wikipedia
très bien pour ça ils sont intimement
critique par rapport à wikipedia dissous
le temps qu'il ya des guerres
d'influencé oui oui c'est marrant mais
c'est sûr sûr sûr sûr mais à la limite
tant mieux c'est intéressant de le
suivre notamment dans tout ce qui est
historique voyez l'histoire quand vous
allez derrière vous allez l'histoire on
efface on remet que c'est intéressant de
voir quand vous suivez vous voyez
question il ya des gardes influence
quelque part c'est intéressant alors moi
je vois wikipédia comme
une source gérer tertiaire ce même pas
une source secondaire ou tertiaire qui
compile des sources secondaires parfois
surpris mer et sur secondaire et ça
permet justement bas d'avoir de faire de
faire un premier tour d'horizon des
luttes d'influencé
donc moi wikipedia mais pas comme outil
de connaissance mais comme outil de
je dirais de lutte d'influencé comme
l'ont très bien dit les internautes ou
et
donc va passer l'objectif de
l'instrumentaliser instrumentalisation
de l'information voulait qu'on ne
revienne dessus sur
l'instrumentalisation de l'information
bah moi ce que je pourrais dire aux
internautes qui sont intéressés par ce
sujet pour éviter de répéter ce que j'ai
dit là dans cette vidéo c'est que ici
c'est une conférence que j'avais fait à
lyon où là je reprends de façon un peu
scolaire un storm 2 de paramètres qui
sont intéressants moi je les invite là
parce que l'ag en 30 minutes j'ai balayé
le semble-t-il à 102 points importants
voilà comment on fait pour faire de la
contre propagande
alors déjà je vais vous dire
ce qui est gênant dans le mot propagande
sait déjà que vous êtes identifié
en tout cas en france parce que si je
vous dis je vais vous faire de la
propagande nature personnes écoutent
donc si je dis maintenant je faire de la
contre propagande voyez alors la
propagande chinoise pour j'ai un peu
regardé propagande russe pour par
exemple la propagande américaine est à
mon avis plus habile parce que l
elles s'appuient souvent sur
des films sur du soft power
sur des événements sur ses plus
indirecte vous laisser moins détectables
donc je pense que si on veut faire de la
bonne
propagande ou contre-propagande l'idéal
c'est quand même de ne pas être
identifiée comme propagandistes voilà et
critique d'identifier comme quoi comme
journaliste comme intellectuel comme
quoi comme professeur comme quoi
j'étais dans un monde idéal savait qu
est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
manipulation de soi je pose la question
à mes étudiants et étudiantes
je le redis une manipulation c'est une
opération par laquelle vous prenez
possession entre guillemets sous les 2
du cerveau de quelqu'un quoi et vous le
piloter à distance sans qu'ils s'en
rendent compte donc là dedans si vous
voulez la discrétion est essentiel la
personne si la personne se rend compte
que elle peut elle peut être consciente
d'être manipulés mais en général l'idéal
c'est qu'elle ne soit pas bon
et l'idéal c'est qu'effectivement
quelque part
elle remercie le sauveur cela le
remercie pardon le marionnettiste
vous avez apporté la démocratie par
exemple un exemple l'ajout donner un
exemple parce que l'idéal c'est que soul
et ça vienne de la personne une personne
qui est manipulé devient réfractaires si
elle se sent manipulé si elle se sent
pas manipuler ces différents
imaginons je prendre l'exemple que je
prends en cours si vous voulez alors par
exemple on parlait des émotions tout à
l'heure une émotion qui marche très bien
pour créer de la dépendance c'est la
peur alors imaginons la est-ce qu'il
faut activer de la peur la peur elle est
partout en ce moment quand c'est pas le
le h1n1 quand c'est pas le chikungunya
quand c'est pas le météorite je sais pas
quoi un réchauffement climatique etc
stade ça c'est d'ailleurs il ya de
vraies raisons là dedans mais donc vous
fait peur et si vous vous ouvrez si vous
voulez votre à l voyez parce que
naturellement quelqu'un qui a peur va
chercher de la protection donc si vous
ouvrez votre aile comme ça et comme soya
marqué solution protection et c'est tout
naturellement sous les la personne va
venir vers vous ce qui est important
dans une manipulation c'est que la
personne se sente libre d'accord c'est
essentiel si la personne se sent
manipulé je vous dise ça ne marche pas
donc il faut toujours que la personne
ait le sentiment d'être libre à partir
de lundi à parano quand même parce que
si chaque fois que l'on élit bonzi
est-ce que je vais pas été manipulée bon
mais effectivement à partir du moment
envoyé où la personne se déplace et
vient sous votre aile petit à petit il
va se créer un nombre de dépendants faim
de points de dépendances et c'est vous
qui allez commencer à dire faites ci
fait ça ne fait pas si nouvelle passât
et petit à petit vous prenez le contrôle
la marionnette voyez il a fait pour
contrer ça
m'a déjà fait en avoir conscience je
pense que s'il est dans une manif
souvent des étudiants qui me dit dont
vous êtes drôlement pervers parce que
finalement vous apprenez à manipuler
géants du ballon justement si je voulais
garder entre guillemets un certain poids
manipulation je ne lançais n'y aurait
pas le seul fait de l'enseigné casse et
ouvre les yeux finalement d'accord donc
le contre est cédé à mon avis c'est déjà
parce que toutes les techniques
aujourd'hui c'est pas de trace nofoot
paint in the snow pas d'empreintes dans
la neige rien d'accord donc à partir de
là il faut être un minimum parano
effectivement
comment dire se poser des questions
connaître les techniques et se dire
attention est ce que je suis est ce que
cet acte que je pose je le pose vraiment
parce que je suis libre où est ce que je
suis
ou est-ce que c'est uniquement
l'illusion d'être libre alors faut pas
rêver non plus parce que il ya des tas
de choses où on n'est pas libre avec un
grand l faut pas rêver sous les coups
bas tout j'ai un autre vie de tous les
jours on est obligé si on roule à droite
la droite
voilà faut pas rêver non plus sur les
bons mais voilà ceci dit je pense que
c'est élever le niveau de conscience des
gens
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire en cours
à leur apprenant à ce terme de technique
pour justement qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient comment dire vigilant des
exemples de technique
je dirais il y en a il y en a beaucoup à
y en a plein l'une 3
banon mais l'une par exemple qui est
connue si vous voulez
qui est d'ailleurs souvent pratiquée
dans le monde du travail c'est ce qu'on
appelle je pense qu'on peut la connaître
c'est la jonction contradictoires bon
c'est à dire que vous donner un ordre
finalement et puis quelque part vous
donner leurs deux confrères donc si vous
dites par exemple à quelqu'un
d'entreprise je veux que vous fermiez
cette filiale mais je veux que tout se
passe très bien d'accord
où je veux que vous réduisiez
vous licencier tout le monde et à la fin
je sois très bien où je réduis votre
budget et vos objectifs de ventes vont
augmenter moins 30 du strand pas ça on
est quelque part sur des injonctions
contradictoires ce qui fait que la
personne
ne sera jamais parfaitement comment dire
nous donnera jamais satisfaction enfin
vous pourrez toujours lui dire quelque
chose qui va pas finalement
et vous lui dites
donc quelque part sous les pour elle le
seul moyen de s'en sortir c'est en fait
d'avoir conscience de ses ordres
contradictoires et de venir lire là je
suis face à deux ordres contradictoires
je ne peux pas faire et l'un et l'autre
et donc je vous demande d'un vin voilà
d'être prioritaires voilà comment quelle
est votre priorité une quelle est votre
priorité de bon un autre moyen de
manipulation que j'ai vu aussi
c'est
pour donner un ordre illégal sous les
loyers vous l'apprendra légal oui même
franchement il est
si vous pouvez pas donner bien sûr un
ordi légal bon mais c'est ça qu'on a
inventé la théorie des baïonnettes
intelligente oui peut-être mais ça va le
moyen classique pour donner un ordre
illégal entre guillemets
et de là aussi il faut ouvrir les yeux
des étudiants leur dire attention ne
soyez pas il n'arrive à être là dedans
c'est ben vous êtes reçus par quelqu'un
qui vous qu'ils s'arrangent pour
qu'évidemment il est pas de témoins
qui va peut être se sentent non pas dans
l'expression mais dans l'implicite et
qui
ne va pas laisser de trace donc pas de
témoin pas d'écrit uniquement de l'oral
et qui va vous dire
[Musique]
alors là je me place dans un dans un
monde de
si vous voulez de gens qui sont prêtes à
tout un donc c'est bon vin
alors tellement nuit
y compris
ce que je veux dire
alors n'ai rien dit sauf que si vous
sélectionnez la personne qui est ca l
peut comprendre d'une certaine manière
et à la fin s'il ya un drame quoi bein
la personne dira
baboo vous pourrez dire n'a jamais donné
cet ordre là mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous avez surinterpréter ce que je
voulais dire et vous avez quand même des
gens si vous voulez qui joue beaucoup à
ça c'est à dire que ils vont être dans
l'implicite voyez ils vont pas vous
donner l'ordre de façon et c'est alors
qu'est ce que je souvent ce que
l'information voilà donc par exemple à
moi ce que je dis souvent à mes
étudiants si vous trouvez face à ce
genre de deux personnes il faut éviter
l'implicite il faut éviter
l'interprétation sortait dans
l'explicité voilà un moment donné
extérioriser l'implicite pour être sûr
d'avoir bien pris et j ça parce que moi
ça a pu m'arriver suis là si on vous dit
vous ennuie donc on est bien d'accord il
vous ennuie bon bah je vais aller lui
dire bah faut que plus qui vous ennuie
vous avez des comptes encore soit serbin
la fabrication de l'opinion
[Musique]
ça c'est en une génération ça sent
combien de générations des as pour des
stations d'opinion déjà qu'est ce que
c'est que l'opinion publique mais c'est
vrai nous prouvent les nombreuses années
déjà qu'est ce que c'est que l'opinion
publique beaucoup de gens pensent que
l'opinion publique c'est si vous vous
laissez
est ce que pense la majorité des gens je
leur dis non c'est pas ce que pense la
majorité des gens c'est ce que vous
pensez que pense la majorité des gens
pas tout à fait pareil d'accord donc
c'est une croyance est ce que alors
médias oui oui j'ai à dire est ce que
tous les jours vous faites brest
strasbourg dunkerque marseille pour
connaître vraiment l'état de l'opinion
publique n'ont donc vous dépendez d'un
sombre d'outils de sondages etc et on va
vous faire croire que il se trouve que
ça c'est intéressant là je peux le site
et j'avais rencontré un haut responsable
une fois dans ma vie de cnn et donc ça
c'était intéressant parce que là pour le
coup voilà j'ai tas de questions à lui
poser et il me dit je lui dis quand même
si elle n en france soit pas très bien
marché parce que peu de gens parlent
anglais et puis vous êtes voilà enfin
c'est bon le peu de chance vous suivent
finalement il me dit oui c'est vrai
sionnel ça marche pas très bien en
france mais
mais bon il me dit c'est quand même
utile dans le monde occidental est aussi
quelque part finalement un peu en france
et j'y pourquoi il dit parce que dans un
monde démocratique comme l'europe quand
vous arrivez à faire croire à une
population qu'elle est minoritaire elle
va se résigner
et effectueront une croyance donc vous
si vous si vous arrivez à dire l'opinion
publique pense la
personnalité en fait si vous dites
l'opinion publique et pour cette grande
cause compte cette grande cause et ces
personnes peut vérifier alors sauf si
vous avez des élections à la fin où il
ya je dirais une preuve sur les
contrôles oui
mais si vous n'avez pas les moyens vous
pouvez jouer là dessus sur cette
croyance et vous pouvez faire en sorte
que les personnes se croyant minorité
alors qu'en fait c'était pas vrai se
résigne
voilà qu'est ce que vous vous parlez de
cnn et de l'influencé du soft power
qu'est ce que vous pensez de rt france
la chaîne russe
par effet miroir si je n'ai rien
et puis et vaches à tous mais aussi je
pense qu'ils jouent sur wii jeu où
chacun joue en fait chacun joue sa carte
comme cctv chênois comme nous et c'est
france 24 c'est ça oui alors écoutez
pour le coup france24 parfois j'aime
beaucoup france 24 ou tv ou et france 24
parfois je les trouve pas assez
patriotique voila voila ce prix c'est un
point de vue que j'ai je trouve que
quand on compte pas alors ils vous
diront bah oui mais sa liberté du
judaïsme je comprends mais tant qu'à
faire une chaîne d' influence autant
qu'elle soit si vous voulez
voilà quelques elle qu'elle défend notre
pays je souhaite entretenir au mieux
quand je vois cctv quand je vois rt
quand je vois à vaches ou des camps
jouent à cnn bon
ou quand je vois
bbc news il ya quand même de façon
implicite l'idée que voilà qu'on joue
pour pour le pays fera bon françois de
cas que fait heins grosso modo mais je
pense qu'on pouvait faire encore mieux
voilà bon mais oui c'est une chaîne
l'affluence moi c'est une chaîne
d'affluence bon bah ils jouent leur jeu
à nous d'être prudent à nous deux
comment comment on fait alors comment on
fait pour être prudent
quand il ya un bbc rti cnn al jazeera et
il a les hommes et la liste est encore
longue comme le bras comment on fait
quand c'est le cerveau des gens le lieu
de deux guerres qu'on dit la lfp en
afrique ces agences trans propagande
vont discuter avec des africains mois
sur internet ils veulent d'abord parce
que moi la fp j'y vais souvent avec mes
propres étudiants et je les trouve assez
professionnel alors voilà bon voilà
bon enfin en tout cas au niveau méthodo
parce que moi ce que je regarde beaucoup
c'est la méthode d'acquisition de
l'information les sources primaires
recoupement des sources primaires le
contradictoire la non caricature
pour moi la fp
c'est pas trop mal enfin la connaissance
fin de ce que je peux voir alors qu'ils
aient des ratés vont sûrement mais à ma
connaissance ils sont pas ils sont pas
dans l'affluence 20 - moins que reuters
ou à sociétés trpa et celle là les
autres franchement moi j'ai eu des
exemples de photos truquées
[Musique]
de bombardements avec des fumées noires
des photos truquées avec des poupées ou
attendait après des bombardements pour
laisser entendre que et c'est bon
là les anglo saxons à mon avis sont
moins lointain de chinois etc mais bon
mais moi je trouve que la fp sincèrement
la question initiale c'était comment on
fait pour résister à toutes ces
propagandes en tant que civil
gg j'en ai discuté avec des journalistes
de partout dans le stade national
comment résister
pourtant xil que ce soit un civil
africains si les européens ainsi les
russes et un civil américain civile sud
américain
comment fait-on pour résister à ça il a
parle
l'endurcissement ou
utilisés au fait que 12 de tous bords
les questions comment on fait pour
s'immuniser défectueuse y pousse moi je
suis important quand on a un contenu moi
ce que je dis toujours à mes étudiants
quand vous avez un contenu première
chose si vous laissez de de cibler la
source et
n'importe quel historien dirait il ya
pas de contenu sans une source parce que
l'historien s'est fait flouer dans
l'histoire oui oui mais quand même ne
soit pas dire oui mais ça veut pas dire
que c'est pas une bonne méthode haut
dès qu'on a dès qu'on a un contenu c'est
qu'elle est la source est ce que c'est
une source tertiaire secondaire primaire
sachant que sur un accident d'automobile
il peut y avoir trois témoins oculaires
et les trois témoins sont pas d'accord
bon mais ce sont ces trois témoins quand
même qu'il faut écouter et non pas moi
si je suis à mille kilomètres l'accident
donc au niveau de la méthode au je pense
qu'une des premières première chose à
faire c'est déjà on peut écarter
beaucoup beaucoup de sources simplement
parce qu'elles sont pas légitimes voilà
ensuite après on peut effectivement
regarder à soupe de source et là c'est
effectivement alors la technique
classique c'est d'essayer d'avoir des
sources un peu dans je dirais sur 360
degrés donc ça prend du temps quand je
tout ce que je vous dis j'ai tout à fait
conscience est-ce que c'est autorisé
dresse à 360 degrés est-ce que c'est
autorisé d'un en europe d'avoir des
sources en russie est ce que c'est
autorisé d'avoir des sources on use est
un moyen non mais il faut des moyens
d'accord il faut se donner les moyens
d'avoir des sources à 360° et être
capable comme une enquête de police de
bâtir je dirais
enfin de faire du contradictoire
c'est-à-dire dans d'écouter une version
voir une deuxième voire une troisième ça
c'est essentiel bon et ensuite
une fois qu'on a ces sources là on
récupère les contenus alors là je parle
de situation où
l'information existe parce que quand
l'information n'existe pas lassé de la
recherche donc là on est dans le domaine
plutôt de données primaires quand jamais
là quand on a du contenu avec des
sources primaires on va déjà essayer de
savoir qui est la source et là il ya un
vrai travail de bio pour savoir si la
source est légitime si
elle y connaît quelque chose si elles
étaient sur place sexta là je renvoie
tout ce que j dans la vidéo
dont je parlais tout à l'heure sur
internet où effectivement on valide la
source si la source est valide et cela
pas dire que le contenu est forcément
vahid et ça c'est important question
interne et qui délivre le diplôme de
légitimité alors justement justement
quand c'est ce que j'appelle des métiers
casquette très bonne question alors
médecins
dentistes sous la paix mettez casquette
donc ses écrits on voit bon ben là c'est
pour un médecin a priori si on a un
professeur du chu 2 bon ça veut pas dire
qu'il a forcément raison enfin il est
légitime pour être écoutés après on peut
tjrs un professeur du chu de machin
chose qui est anti vaccin fait comment
oui bah il faut il faut aller chercher
d'autres posteurs il faut aller dans le
contradictoire aller chercher d'autres
professeurs du dot chu etc et écouter un
peu tout le monde voilà c'est ce qui est
important savoir des sources des experts
avec beaucoup de faux experts et je suis
d'accord mais ça c'est un vrai vrai
trail donc légitimité que ensuite après
une fois qu'on a fait ce travail de
collecte des sources et de collecte
ensuite des des contenus ce qui est
intéressant c'est de rapprocher les
contenus et déjà de regarder mais ça
c'est aussi du travail ce qui est
convergence qui divergent si au niveau
des parce que quand vous prenez même des
experts sont pas d'accord entre eux il
ya quand même des domaines où ils sont
d'accord donc là vous rapprocher les
contenus et vous regardez déjà ce qu
elles convergent bon si tous les experts
sont déjà convergent sur ça là ça vous
donne déjà saoul et un bon socle de
vérité sur un certain nombre de points
après vous avez tous qui divergent bon
divergent ça c'est un vrai problème
alors souvent nous ce que l'on fait
avec mes étudiants etc sur certains
sujets que l'on traite on fait venir les
sources primaires légitime que l'on a
identifié et en effet dialoguer sur les
points de divergence on se rend compte
qu'on peut encore un peu réduire
l'incertitude bon ensuite après je vous
dire voilà il ya cette incertitude avec
un grand gros point d'interrogation ou
là bas soit on peut continuer bon soit
il faudra peut-être attendre 100 ans
deux siècles trois siècles pour avoir le
dernier pezou les derniers posts du
dernière pièce du puzzle voyez bon mais
l'idée c'est toujours ça c'est partir
des contenus ensuite de centrer sur les
sources de travail et les sources
d'aller chercher d'autres sources
contradictoires et ensuite de récupérer
auprès de ces sources les contenus et
ensuite de recouper les contenus
convergent divergent alors deux
questions internet dans la presse n'est
pas une question mais je vais passer
quand même parce que c'est très serré
donc heureux de voir mon ancien
professeur d'intelligence économique
chez singer review lourdines
franco-algérien du cnam de nancy
promotion 2016 un grand bon soir à
dessaler merci lotina question
comment quelqu'un qui doit travailler
toute la journée pour se nourrir peut-il
avoir le temps de se faire un avis
éclairé avec la méthode qu'il décrit
c'est une bonne question
votre internaute n'est pas le premier à
me l'avoir dit et effectivement
je me souviens ma mère ma femme me l'ont
dit mais tu méthodes elles sont bien
mais c'est très long j'ai dit oui c'est
des méthodes en fait d'intelligence
économique de services de renseignement
etc le alors à un moment donné dans
l'urgence dans l'urgence ce qu'il faut
c'est essayer effectivement d'avoir des
sources secondaires pour ça on revient
aux journalistes les bons journalistes
ceux à qui on peut faire confiance
bon et là c'est ce qu'ils sont pas en
laisse soudain et voilà elle alors là
c'est difficile alors parlant dans le
domaine économique en france on a quand
même un bon qui est lu par tout le monde
et qui est quand même assez crédible
j'espère dû choquer personne mais enfin
et quand je dis ça ce sont de vrais des
gauches non c est qu au bond les échos
c'est pas c'est pas drôle drôle non
c'est pas un journal qui est drôle drôle
mais c'est quand même assez
assez
factuel ch a tenté de dire assez factuel
alors c'est derrière il ya une
philosophie voilà plutôt libérale
extérieur d'accord mais
voilà alors vous avez je pense qu'on
peut pas si vous voulez on peut pas se
passer de bons journalistes
c'est quoi votre vote à votre constat
sur le journalisme en france quand on
sait qu un mois lors duquel protection
qui doit évoluer 90 morceaux 90% soleil
tenus par des oligarques que la majeure
partie sont si souvent c'est un métier
qui doit évoluer je veux dire pourquoi
alors je sais que j'ai pas mal d'amis
jouer je peux les choquer mais je le
redis ce qui est terrible c'est que cite
par exemple lactalis vend du lait
frelaté tout le monde tombe dessus bon
ce qui est normal un journaliste
gilles roux d'un couvent une information
frelaté alors on peut bien sûr on peut
on peut
demander un droit de réponse et que ça
avant mais dans la pratique sous les
cils et habile bon et s'il reste dans le
nom faux avec les bons conditionnel les
bons points d'interrogation les bons
éléments les bons finalement comme le 10
heures mais promet chez les indigènes ce
qu'ils me disent qu'on peut dire des
mensonges en ne disant des vérités 1
vous assemblez des vérités à la fin ça
fait un bon changement donc
voilà donc
je pense est une profession jeu l'idée
que vous avez émis ce planeur d'un code
de déontologie ça je vois très bien
s'est passé ça a été patiemment te voilà
mai mais bon il faut il flagellation
journalistique au tour de france
télévision pour dire on n'a pas fait
notre boulot on n'a pas vu les jets
déjoue devenir nos informations sont pas
respectées non mais à mon avis ya
quelque chose à faire c'est trop tard il
ya quelque chose à faire oui oui je
pense pension genre de bouquin
bah je pense que même s'ils voulaient
souffre déjà avec internet tout le monde
aujourd'hui est journaliste sur internet
les journalistes sont sous les sons sont
voilà le même c'est que beaucoup ont
perdu certaine forme de crédibilité et
légitimité
donc les gens se tournent vers
l'internet dans mais un vrai vrai
problème parce que vendent un produit
payant donc le produit payant pour être
payant il faut qu'il soit bien meilleure
donc ça certains journaux l'ont compris
un don qui vont regarder tout ce qui est
fait chaque 1 et c'est alors que la sp
et d'autre le parisien extermine 20
minutes et ça tout le monde ils ont
compris qu'il faut qu'ils vendent un
produit qui quand même essaye essaye
d'approcher au mieux la vérité sachant
que parfois la vérité ce sont plusieurs
vérités c'est compliqué mais à mon avis
c'est quand même c'est dans cette
direction qu'il faut aller
et puis
certaine forme de neutralité
d'objectivité
apporter quelque chose que les autres
n'apporte pas
donc le journal soit apporter une vraie
valeur ajoutée au niveau
l'analyse
des pertes mises en perspectives etc je
trouve qu'un pour moi un bon journaliste
c'est un intermédiaire oui et nous en
tant que prof on est obnubilé par
l'exigence de vérité quand même on
essaye de d'avoir une approche
scientifique bon je comprends tout à
fait que les journalistes
qui sont un peu qui court après le temps
est une difficulté à ils sont plus
d'argent et voilà il faut gagner
d'argent puisque les résout très tôt
présenté en jardin des vérités
successives finalement bon mais quelque
part je dirais pour moi un bon
journaliste il doit tendre vers cette
exigence de vérité
au maximum sinon je crains qu'ils
fectivement qui bat qui disparaissent
parce que sinon autant parce que quand
même faut pas oublier que la journal
c'est payant donc si on paye fo qui est
quand même quelque chose de plus et de
mieux question d'internet comme on
vérifie que la source n'est pas rémunéré
par des lobbys bah ça c'est justement
c'est une très très bonne question parce
que ça fait partie des paramètres que je
donne dans cette vidéo dont je m'arrête
à l'heure où effectivement il faut voir
si la source est indépendante si la
source n'est pas indépendante bah on l'a
vu on l'a vu dans certains dossiers là
récents dans le domaine médical et ses
laboratoires externes si les sources
sont payés forcément ils sont alors
elles peuvent elles peuvent être
suspecte mais attention parce que alors
non rémunéré ça c'est suspect ça c'est
sûr maintenant si la source appartient
force simplement à je dirais par exemple
imaginons une source qui appartiennent à
une société pour nom total est ce que
parce que la personne travaille chez
total est ce qu'elle est suspecte parce
que justement être allé chez total et
qu'elle va forcément défendre l'idée fin
des formes total pas forcément là aussi
c'est plus complexe qu'on pourrait le
penser parce que certaines personnes
vont vous dire oui on va pas interroger
quelqu'un de chez total forcément il va
défendre total oui et non parce qu'en
même temps il connaît total de
l'intérieur et peut-être qu'il aura une
certaine liberté sinon ça dépend des
personnes liberté de parole et peut-être
que justement
il va pouvoir apporter des éléments qui
seront un peu divergents par rapport à
ce qu'on aurait dit tout à la question
internet quel a été l'événement cli
qu'il a éveillé et rendu critique face à
l'information
qui mois alors quel a été l'événement
qui m'a rendu critique quel a été
l'événement cli qu'il a éveillé et rendu
critique pas cette information alors moi
bon la présentation j'ai pas voulu
raconter ma vie c'est pas le but mais
j'ai passé une partie de ma jeunesse en
union soviétique
parce que mon père travaillait en union
soviétique et donc là j'ai été confronté
si vous voulez en direct à beaucoup de
choses
[Musique]
et entre autres justement au fait que la
presse n'était pas libre du tout bon et
que
il y avait tant de choses qui ne sortait
pas et que c'était quand même
intéressant d'avoir une presse libre
parce que finalement se forger une
meilleure opinion de la réalité donc moi
ç'a commencé très tôt ce passage en
union soviétique m'a ouvert les yeux sur
pas mal de choses d'abord effectivement
l'intérêt d'une presse libre et puis
d'autre part
l'intérêt aussi de la concurrence je
suis devenu assez assez comment dire
favorable à la concurrence régulée un
pas n'importe comment mais la
concurrence parce que la concurrence
crée de la performance et ça moi je me
souviens moscou quand j'allais chez le
coiffeur quand je vais faire mes courses
c'est moi qui souvent bon y aller pour
mes parents et donc je voyais l'état de
délabrement de l'économie soviétique et
je me disais et chaque fois que je pose
la question me disais moi je ne sais pas
de concurrence ça marche pas bien extra
donc voilà c'est 2-2 vérité
kim enfin que j'ai acquise là-bas le
bien fondé d'une concurrence de la
concurrence certaine pour créer de la
performance et puis l'autre chose c'est
effectivement
le
la force d'avoir une une
une presse libre alors après voilà les
chinois vous diront ça c'est j'ai
commencé comme ça tout à l'heure mais
ils vous disent les français adorent
discuter mais il n'aime pas décidé
c'est terrible d'entendre ça parce que
ils vous disent moi je les ai entendus
en cour ils vous disent les français
sont très sensibles à la liberté
d'expression mais c'est normal c'est
parce qu'ils aiment discuter des dix
quinze des dix caves des disques ssd
dans flight to decide mais il n'aime pas
décidé c'est alors après les chinois
disent ah bon mais alors pourquoi il
aime pas déçu mais c'est comme ça il
adore discuter discuter discuter il ya
des polémiques sans arrêt le pays est
immobile mais il ya une apparence de
mouvement avec des polémiques
à foison
mais voilà et alors c'est là où c'est
vrai que quand on discute avec d'autres
étrangers ils me disent souvent avec en
france vous avez les polémiques vous
aimez parfois la discussion un peu
stérile mais vous ne décidez pas bon
moi je les ai vus dans beaucoup de
domaines un big data etc ça bouge pas
beaucoup c'est lent et c'est donc je
suis pour la liberté de la presse à fond
à fond à fond à fond
mais ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on
arrive si vous voulez à
je dirais un moment donné à clore les
débats à discuter et puis à avancer tous
ensemble
même si la décision ne nous convient pas
et si on peut
agiter la légitimité pour contrer la
décision qui est prise parce que
finalement c'est ça qui nourrit ses de
cet immobilisme
finalement qui
vous dit vous dit qu'on se perd dans des
dans des polémiques qu'on se perd dans
temps du brassage de fumi du
sculpteur d'air chaud est ce que de
temps en temps même souvent
l'information n'est pas instrumentalisée
pour faire des effets des grands fermés
vous avez des exemples où la formation
est un écran de fumée déployés pour
éviter que l'opinion publique ça tarde
trop sur un sujet qui pourrait mettre à
mal le pouvoir bah c'est à dire on
détourne l'attention oui bah vous avez
un bon pas le nommer m'enfin tout le
monde ne trouvera vous avez un homme
politique qui est à une épouse qui je
crois que j'entends voilà qui fait de la
guitare et qui chante bon bah si vous
pouvez couper à tout moment voilà où
fait diversion mais ça oui mais ça ils
le font au sein ils le font tous et vous
vous pouvez effectivement créer un
événement pour
pour détourner l'attention c'est ce que
j'appelle des informations enfin tout le
monde le sait les informations fumigènes
c'est à dire que on a allumé un fumigène
et tout le tout le stade regarde regarde
dans la même direction donc plus
personne ne regarde voilà bon oui c'est
là où si vous voulez comme je le dis
dans cette vidéo je pense qu'il faut
former nos citoyens nos jeunes et quoi
de mieux à mon avis quelle que le cours
d'histoire géographie ou là on pourrait
former nos jeunes toutes ces techniques
justement lié à la réception de
l'information
je pense que les profs d'histoire
géographie serait très très bon en plus
ils ont cette formation d'historien la
source et ça il faudrait pas grand chose
pour que nos jeunes en première
terminale soit formé à s'aguerrir fait
que news voilà c'est ça c'est ça mais
parce que l'état est ce que l'état un
besoin d'un public a chuté je pense que
regarder l'état a fait quelque chose il
ya quelques années qu'ils étaient de mon
point de vue très bien
il a formé
enfin il ya une une deux trois journées
sur les théories du complot avec les
théories du complot ont fleuri ces
dernières années pour toutes sortes de
raisons et cette théorie du complot
kenzy bat parce que les gens sont avides
de ce qu'on peut comprendre
d'explication ils veulent des
explications c'est difficile ça et je
vous disais de rester cinq ans je ne
sais pas c'est très difficile dans la
tsr vous connaissez la pyramide de
maslow on vous dit le premier besoin les
premiers besoins sont les besoins
physiologiques externe moi je dis non
les premiers besoins sont pas les
besoins physiologiques boire seul c'est
les besoins informationnels parce que
pour boire il faut oui la rivière seul
est bon et c'est très difficile
franchement de reste il faut avoir
quelque chose à dire il faut avoir
confiance il faut jeudi c'est très
difficile de
dire je ne sais pas
parce que
si vous voulez vous avez toujours une
tendance à vouloir expliquer c'est
quelque chose qui est naturel la
personne ne peut rester comme ça et les
explications les explications les plus
simples les plus globalisante les plus
intuitifs passe toujours très bien moi
je détestais à mille fois et dans les
explications simples globalisante
intuitive pas contre intuitif intuitive
bon bah ça peut des explications
idéologique ça peut être des
explications parfois religieuse ça peut
te voyais est bon et donc ses
explications un peu
simple intuitive qui permet d'expliquer
beaucoup de choses plus c'est simple
plus globalisant mieux c'est et c'est
vrai que c'est très difficile
franchement dressait en fait faut faire
un effort sur soi même pour dire qui est
simple et court le passeport direct pour
le slogan idéologique pur
d'accord et vous connaissez le rasoir
d'occam le rasoir d'occam non on en
discutera peut-être un peu plus tard on
arrive à la fin de notre interview parce
que ça commence à faire lourd la sptr je
ne m'ennuie pas des internautes non non
non ils sont ils sont il ya beaucoup de
questions ils sont bien présents et donc
je vais passer quelques dernière
question vous informer comment vous vous
disais quoi vous avez alors moi j'ai la
chance de pouvoir alimenter en plusieurs
langues donc
je me force si vous voulez à lire
bon beaucoup de
journaux sélectionnés pas uniquement
qu'en français ça
j'essaye de même je m'impose de lire
systématiquement des journaux étrangers
j'essaye toujours de recouper alors
évidemment il ya les sujets qui ne sont
pas impliquant donc la bomba je regarde
ça de loin sous la pression des sujets
où je suis impliqué ou la
systématiquement quand je mène une
enquête je remet le compteur à zéro
systématiquement jeu c'est difficile et
je repars je laisse de côté mes
intuitions mes préjugés enfin j'essaye
mais a priori etc et puis petit à petit
je construis je construis mon
investigation
alors effectivement je moi ce qui
ce qui me caractérise c'est que j'essaye
toujours si vous voulez de trouver des
experts des sources primaires bon sur
linkedin j'ai trente quatre mille
contacts il n'y a pas que des experts
mais il ya aussi pas mal de témoins
oculaires il ya pas mal de personnes
seraient ravis d'accueillir tous les
experts qui le souhaiteront pas
forcément parce que c'est marc experts à
mais parce que on peut être expert moi
je suis à des domaines sur lequel je
sais je suis expert puis les tas de
domaines où je suis pas expert du tout
donc voilà je me tais bon en revanche
aujourd'hui si vous voulez ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est une manière un peu
détournée de répondre c'est que ce soir
je serai plus il n'y aura en valeur
relative que ce matin puisque la
connaissance accrue comme ça moi je
n'arrive pas à suivre cette croissance
de la croissance exponentielle donc ce
soir je serai plus un relatifs en valeur
relative je serais plus ignorant ce qui
veut dire que je me dois de compenser
cette ignorance donc pas en apprenant ce
je veux pas mais en allant chercher
toujours
d'aider des sources experte des sources
primaires etc et de me dire chaque fois
je suis de plus en plus ignorants donc
prudents peu dans ce jeu c'est de moins
en moins tous les jours bon il ya une
question une question un peu provoc
d'internet
volontairement à mon avis décalé ne
peut-on pas simplement écouter entre
guillemets les mauvais journalistes pour
en déduire la réalité des choses en gros
est ce que c'est pas plus intéressant
d'écouter la propagande des autres pour
savoir en fait tout le terrain et de
moore
j'ai pas d'idée
ce serait par là je dirais la preuve par
l'absurde mais bon
on en a fini d des questions
fini question est-ce que vous avez des
choses à aborder encore avec nous qu'on
n'a pas abordé vous avez un sujet en
particulier
[Musique]
reviendra la prochaine fois est-ce que
vous avez trois bouquins et conseiller
nos internes alors je m'attendais à la
question est là bas je vais être un
petit peu voilà rebelles pas donc je
vais pas recommander des bouquins parce
que justement je trouve que il faut en
lire bien sûr mais ce que je voudrais
c'est que moi je je voudrais que nos
jeunes en fait
[Musique]
liv bien sûr mais moi j'ai plutôt des
des recommandations à faire conseil le
concerne les jeunes générations c'est un
printemps
je vais repasser une autre question
d'internet pourquoi pourquoi y at il
autant de silence sur la colonisation
dans les livres d'histoire
question de hassan
pourquoi autant que silence sur la
colonisation
est un sujet qui est forcément un peu
bon un peu polémique parfois un peu
tabou c'est difficile d'expliquer
c'est difficile moi quand genre élevé
j'enseigne en algérie au sénégal
en afrique c'est un sujet je sais
qu'elle est toujours polémique difficile
alors on arrive à discuter si vous
voulez des bienfaits des mauvais
des mauvais côtés de lago bailly de la
mondialisation de la colonisation pardon
mais
je pense que c'est
c'est pour éviter de c'est pour éviter
de susciter des polémiques mais c'est un
vrai parce que la colonisation joue à
côté en france et en algérie forcément
c'est pas du tout la même vision donc là
ce que j'entends d'un côté ce que
j'entends de l'autre moi j'essaye
d'expliquer en algérie j'essaye
d'expliquer
si vous voulez aussi les bons côtés
quand même bon voilà pour dire que de
mon point de vue il n'y avait pas
forcément que des monstres
que les français sont arrivés bon après
l'empiré ottoman qu'il y avait un sur
deux et qu'on a apporté quand la nation
de choses dont la presse était pas
parfait c'est sûr là je suis d'accord
mais voilà aux questions internet pensez
vous qu'il s'agit d'avoir les outils
pour décrypter l'information ou plutôt
le fait que les gens ne sont pas prêts à
accepter la vérité ça c'est une
excellente question je dirai ça
savez c'est très difficile de convaincre
moi parfois quand je sens que les
personnes sont dans une croyance qui
s'est pas foulée de la croyance et qui à
un moment donné c'est de la fois avec un
grand f
donc qu'est ce que c'est que la fois
c'est la personne qui croit tellement
qu'elle balaye l'épreuve
[Musique]
on peut comprendre parce que la croyance
la fois
comment dire c'est lié à l'identité
d'une personne voyez vous avez deux
manières de sortir du jeu ne sais pas
soit vous savez
soit vous croyez
est-ce qu'on se définit par rapport à la
connaissance souvent je m'amuse en cours
je demande à mes étudiants comme ça
jardi alors est ce que vous pourriez
vous définir par rapport aux règles de
multiplication alors il me regarde
non
sauf en chine où là ils me disent je
veux pas de la règle de migration de 4
sec le quatrième de la mort huit ce lieu
le 8 cm le six aussi voilà si ces mythes
voilà mais parce qu'en fait c'est une
croyance et donc après quand on aborde
le problème des croyances la effectuant
les gens se définissent par rapport à
leurs croyances donc ils se définissent
et leur identité ont fait plus marche
arrière c'est plus difficile de faire
marche arrière comprenez vous là vous
vous y mettez une partie de vous même
vous y mettez une partie de votre
personne de votre identité et donc bon
je respecte les personnes qui ont des
croyances forte des convictions fortes
mais parfois vous avez des approches sur
un ensemble de sujets politiques
internationaux extérieur qui s'approche
qui je dirais sont économiques
économiques qui peuvent je dirais des
approches un peu religieuses entre
guillemets ça veut dire voyez où les
gens sont plus tellement dans la
connaissance scientifique mais dans une
approche uniquement sur la base de
croyance et là en général quand je vois
que j'ai à faire avec un croyant saouler
avec un grand c mais pas religieux
croyants en général si je vois que la
personne
ne soulève ne peut pas entendre les
arguments de la raison et c'est à ce
moment là je vois je suis toujours polis
respectueux mais
je cherchais pas l'idée d'utiliser
bas je sais que ça serait peut-être
temps qu'un autre mais je vois là oui un
j'ai pas la méthode de je pense souvent
que ça sert à rien donc si les gens sont
dans une logique d coûte oui il ya sur
les si les gens sont capables déjà de
dire voilà je ne sais pas où de douter
un peu de leur croyance pourquoi pas
mais si les personnes vous voyez affirme
et c'est bon alors de temps en temps je
suis pas en train de dire que la
croyance il faut supprimer la croyance
parce que la croyance a quand même deux
points positifs la première chose c'est
que c'est quand même le préalable à la
connaissance il faut croire avant de
connaître et puis c'est fédérateur c'est
fédérateur et c'est si vous voulez quand
vous êtes manager moi je prends beaucoup
de managers un manager il a besoin d'eux
s'ils voulaient de quelque part
d'instrumentaliser la vérité pour en
faire un outil si vous voulez de de
motivation car les valorisations voilà
c'est par exemple imaginons un match de
football obama joue une finale bon vous
avez un grand club
de division 1 qui joue contre un tout
petit club et l'entraîneur du petit club
va pas dire écoutez on joue contre un
grand club de division 1 sont tous des
internationaux il vise la champion's
league et vise éventuellement de la
gagne et claque la claque à la limite
n'y a pas besoin de jouer le sur tapis
vert s'est perdu au contraire là il va
dire la vérité devant nous
ce sont des professionnels donc sur les
des matches il en joue tous les trois
jours bon ok ils vont être un peu
motivés pour celui-là mais nous c'est le
match de notre vie ce sont des êtres
humains c'est que ça donc il va croyez
yves active a en fait créé une croyance
pour surmotiver son équipe et où est
donc la croyance c'est aussi nécessaire
en management en motivation ça d'apollon
faisait très bien il en riant d'être un
napoléon quand on regarde la bataille
d'austerlitz est vraiment intéressant
d'abord on voit que si vous voulez
kutuzov moi je pense est assez naïvement
que napoléon arrive sous les dans la
plaine de faim slave cov la maintenance
et slaves coffre austerlitz autrefois
bon et puis qu'on lui dit tiens tiens il
ya un coût tout sauf derrière bon ben ok
pas de mon fait de morphine bataille
j'étais vraiment très naïf de croire ça
en fait pas du tout si vous voulez vous
aviez
depuis plusieurs semaines napoléon avait
envoyé à son de janeiro pour les
identifier les bons champ de bataille ce
que l'époque n'avait pas de carte donc
on envoyait les topographes hextadon
petit à petit on identifie ce champ de
bataille qui est pas mal bon ensuite il
faut positionner kutuzov canton comme on
le veut et c'est donc ça c'est tout le
travail avant d'anticipations de 2 mise
en place du champ de bataille et puis
napoléon tout le monde le sait la veille
du du 2 décembre 1805 dans la nuit qui
précède il fait le tour de tout le monde
parce que et il dit pas assez à ces
soldats ses grognards vous savez ils
sont beaucoup plus que nous de l'autre
côté d'un an et lors du son va gagner et
cetera vous avez donc il est surmotivé
tout est donc la fin ça fait une très
fine très belle victoire voyez donc la
croyance napoléon savez très bien joué
et de la connaissance et de la croyance
pour surmotiver donc la salle ans est
nécessaire certains enfants ont fait une
chose même d'ailleurs quand ils
perdaient les batailles
que pense-t-il de l'action de macro
sur piège écoutez attendons de voir je
dirais moi j'attends les résultats si
vous voulez ce que j'espère c'est que
ce que je souhaite c'est que nos deux
pays s'en sorte voilà pensée qui va un
peu ensemble de notre pays
quand tiennent responsable de la sûreté
nationale ou là le responsable de
l'enseignement qui dit notre pays sans
sauvageonne étant sauvage et bah on est
que le niveau de haine n'a jamais été
ans on est un peu dans le réel débat je
vous ai tout à l'heure la légitimité et
illégalité etc
on est donc ça c'est une première
manière de deux voix on est aussi dans
cette logique
un peu tous ces mouvements de colère
mondiaux qui émergent partout mais où
les citoyens
dieu merci
franchissent certaines certain seuil de
violence mais ne veulent pas aller pour
quand même pour de très bonnes raisons
au delà d'un certain seuil ou qu'ils ne
peuvent pas ou qui ne peuvent pas
exercer une surveillance ibérique ou
bien un maillage du territoire de choses
comme ça les coûts 1782 ça fait bien
longtemps que les travaux et l'etat sera
tombé dans les airs mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'en fait
on ce que je vois moi un peu dans tous
les pays du monde c'est que les
gouvernements fait qu'on tienne la
colère pour l'instant on est dans un
espace à la fois d'explosion des colères
ça je suis d'accord et en même temps
dans des mouvements de housse est cool
cette colère est contenue et où pour
l'instant elle arrive à être contenue
alors certains me dit c'est ça qui va
être intéressant à suivre certains
collègues que j'ai d'ailleurs des
chinois des algériens des sénégalais des
profs me disent est ce que cette colère
contenue va déboucher sur une impasse ou
pas et là c'est vrai quand je dirais de
manière intellectuelle c'est intéressant
de voir voilà ce qu'ils comment tous ces
mouvements parce que même au venezuela a
envoyé finalement plus de cette colère
ça pour la santé en fait c'est quelque
part ça débouche sur pas grand chose
quoi finalement ceddat colère contenue
c'est sûr que ça fait ça le niveau de
conscience de tout le monde on a été
élevé tout le monde se dit a sûrement
des choses à faire etc mais pour autant
voilà
est-ce que ça entraîne des gros
changements de direction au niveau des
gouvernements tout ça pour l'instant
pas vraiment donc à suivre question
qu'on pose souvent est-ce que vous avez
un ami imaginer un ce que vous croyez
dans une religion grand tout un grand
leader alors quelqu'un qui vit dans les
nuages
alors je peux alors ça j'ai pas voulu
mais quand je suis en cours je vous
présente ce que je suis centriste de
droite voilà six ans en drizzt côté
droit
et je suis catholique pratiquant voilà
donc je donne tout mais tous mes billets
même si j'essaye d'être le plus neutre
possible et le plus objectif possible
voilà donc on va arriver la fin est-ce
que vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ben en fait j'aime moi j'en
avais trois 3 conseils pour nos jeunes
un premier conseil c'est je le redis
c'est allé en chine aller à shanghai
ces 400 c'est pas très cher ses 400 si
vous vous débrouillez bien pouvait faire
l'aller-retour pour 460 euros un peu
moins de 500 ça vaut le coup une fois
vous êtes sur place vous déjeunez pour 4
5 euros
twist 1 ou 2 to non alors non justement
là c'est le bon côté des
restaurant de rue chinois c'est que moi
je suis jamais tombé malade jamais dans
d'autres pays où il est un peu dans son
pays oui oui mais quand même nom mais en
général ça va bon donc voilà pourquoi j
la chine et pourquoi changer le soleil
c'est un choc quand j c'est un choc
c'est un choc moi je suis allé à
shanghai 16 est mon 94ème pays si vous
les bons et je pensais pas que ce serait
un tel choc et c'est encore un choc
aujourd'hui sur les quand j'y vais quand
je vois plus d'ong de nuit illuminée que
ça mais c'est
c'est l'impressionnant soul et donc ça
il faut y aller parce que pour tous nos
jeunes la chine seul et on sent que le
voilà le notre allié américain est la
conséquence est ce que c'est encore des
doigts de change je pense cette bouger
en tout cas il y en a un autre j'ai
passé à votre analyse ou pas mais il y
en a un autre qui émerge de l'autre côté
donc je pense que l'europe va devoir un
peu jouer si vous voulez je pense qu'on
va jouer un jeu qu'on connaissait pas
avant un peu
là contre l'autre ou l'un avec l'autre
extra ça va être un jeu de balance si on
arrive à s'affirmer c'est bien sinon on
va être obligé un petit peu de jouer un
peu les intermédiaires sur les voiliers
bon mais je crois qu'il faut aller en
chine ça c'est sûr sûr sûr et je le dis
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas vu depuis
le temps que j'organise des visites de
fin des missions d'études à shanghai ou
dans d'autres villes mais en tous cas
surtout shanghai
j'ai pas vu une seule personne pas une
seule pas une seule me dire qu'elle
avait regretté pas une seule ensuite un
deuxième projet c je voudrais que les
étudiants fin mai mais de plus en plus
que mes étudiants mènent des projets
voyez fasse un projet et si possible un
projet collectif voilà parce que peint
pas uniquement individuelle mais quelque
chose ensemble
mais au bout jusqu'au bout quelque chose
ça peut être une grande cause ça peut
être un projet politique ça peut être un
projet social ça peut être un projet
sportif théâtrale peu importe mais un
projet partir en chine et puis faire
quelque chose avec d'autres voilà et se
battre mon mot de la fin c'est se battre
se battre se battre ne jamais renoncer
se battre jusqu'au bout jusqu'à votre
dernier souffle même quand vous avez un
genou à terre vous vous battez vous
battez renoncer jamais battez vous et
comme ça je dirais vous arriverez si
vous voulez à la victoire si on est
quand même dans un monde de compétition
et faut se battre voilà christophe
starsbourg guillebaud disons merci merci
coupé
[Musique]
holmes